Tim Ferriss: Hello ladies and gentlemen.
This is Tim Ferriss and this is yet another
edition of The Random Show, episode number
4,732.
Kevin Rose.
Kevin Rose: We've done quite a few.
Tim Ferriss: Serial entrepreneur.
Amazing.
Good fella.
Generous soul.
Kevin Rose: Thank you.
Tim Ferriss: In spirit.
Kevin Rose: [inaudible 00:01:27] doing these
podcasts together.
We did quite a few episodes.
Tim Ferriss: Avid wearer of trucker hats.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And drinker of red wine as we've
already established by the sound effects that
preceded this introduction.
Kevin, nice to see you.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, it's good to see you as
well.
We need to do this in person more often.
We did one in the last year.
Tim Ferriss: We do.
It was so fun.
It was so fun to do it in person.
Kevin Rose: I know.
Tim Ferriss: So what nectar of the gods are
you suckling over there?
Kevin Rose: Yes.
I'm having a little bit of The Mascot from
Napa Valley.
The Harlan family, we know Will, obviously,
over there and they are quality producers
of quite fine cabernet red wine that is just
amazing.
This is my favorite.
To be fair, I'm conflicted a little bit because
I am on their advisory board, but they make
great wine.
Tim Ferriss: They do make great wine.
Kevin Rose: It's fantastic wine.
Tim Ferriss: I've been over yonder back when
I was living in NorCal.
You and I had quite a bit of that even before
you were on the board.
Very, very tasty grapes.
Tasty, tasty grapes.
Kevin Rose: Absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: They can put that on the label,
if they want, as a quote.
Kevin Rose: Tasty Grapes from Tim.
[inaudible 00:02:38] back, founder of CØCKPUNCH.
Tasty Grapes.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
Kevin Rose: I'm sure that'll do wonders for
their floor price of their—
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah, for that very high
and top shelf legacy, multi-generational branding
that they're going after.
I think that would really help.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
That's what they want is tasty grapes.
Tim Ferriss: Tasty grapes.
I am drinking...
I don't know if you've ever seen this before,
this thing-
Kevin Rose: No.
Tim Ferriss: ... which I'm drinking.
It's this little can of R 1,3 Ginger Mule
hard ketones.
So this is ethanol-free-
Kevin Rose: Oh, Jesus.
Tim Ferriss: ... alcohol.
Hold on.
I have other ethanol alcohol.
Kevin Rose: You're drinking hard ketones now?
That's where we're at?
Tim Ferriss: Hold on.
Pause.
Don't knock it until you've tried it.
Kevin Rose: I'm not going to [inaudible 00:03:27].
Tim Ferriss: So R 1,3 Butanediol, I know where
you're going to take that.
So the R 1,3 Butanediol, a few things.
Number one is you do get drunk on this stuff.
You cannot drive if you drink this stuff-
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: ... all alcohol, pretty much.
Like all alcohol, but the point being that
it is not ethanol so you are avoiding some
of the metabolites and issues through liver
metabolism that you run into with regular
alcohol.
It is also an appetite suppressant so if you're
used to drinking and then just housing five
pizzas like I did the other night, then this
is a counterbalance.
And what I've been constantly [inaudible 00:04:12].
Kevin Rose: It speeds you up though.
It's ketones, right?
So it's like coke alcohol.
Tim Ferriss: Well, here's the thing.
No, it's ketones but it's not beta hydroxybutyrate
or a performance-enhancing ketone.
This is a hard ketone intoxicant.
So you have to be very careful.
They have warnings.
No pregnant ladies, et cetera, all this stuff.
Do not consume more than three day.
Kevin Rose: Oh, my god, dude.
[inaudible 00:04:35].
Tim Ferriss: You legitimately get intoxicated
when you drink this, so you have to be very
careful but it contains-
Kevin Rose: Does it burn when you pee?
Tim Ferriss: No, it does not burn with when
you pee.
It does not give you horns or vestigial tail
or eyelid hair, none of those things, and
I have been enjoying experimenting with this
because what I will sometimes do, and I haven't
done this much, but I will have one of these-
Kevin Rose: You're an investor, I can tell.
Look, you're sipping [inaudible 00:05:02]
investment.
Tim Ferriss: I am not an investor.
Yeah, this is like the Wayne's world [inaudible
00:05:09] drinking Pepsi-
Kevin Rose: You're like, "I will have one
of these every night at 7:00 PM."
Tim Ferriss: No, I am not an investor.
I have no vested interest.
Unlike that shill, Kevin Rose, I have no vested-
Kevin Rose: I said I was involved.
I almost spit the grape juice that you called
it or whatever you-
Tim Ferriss: Tasty.
Kevin Rose: Tasty grapes, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So yeah, I am not involved.
I have no problem hawking the stuff when I
am, but this is actually very tasty.
So Ginger Mule tastes like a Moscow Mule,
but it has no ethanol-based alcohol in it,
and here's what I'm going to do.
So I'm going to have this first.
Hopefully, and this is, I think, perhaps wishful
thinking, but I'm hoping the ketones will
have some neuroprotective effect so that when
I then shift into fifth gear to have this,
which is a tequila I've become very, very
fond of...
I'm not involved, but I have been drinking
it because I had it first at a restaurant
called Suerte here in Austin which has excellent
TexMex food, very high end, outstanding cuisine.
And the first time I had this that the server
recommended was at that restaurant when I
was having dinner with Chase Jarvis and we
were both blown away.
Kevin Rose: I love Chase.
Tim Ferriss: Chase is a great guy.
Chase [inaudible 00:06:29].
Kevin Rose: [inaudible 00:06:29].
Tim Ferriss: Both wonderful humans, and we
were both really impressed with this and I
enjoyed it so much that I ended up buying
a bottle, which is quite rare for me because
I don't drink that much but I do really like
tequila.
I mean, if you were in Texas and you drink
alcohol, you owe it to yourself to explore
the range of tequila, and this stuff is outstanding,
it's just fantastic.
This will be step two.
Kevin Rose: I have two questions for you.
Actually, one question.
You can cut this later if you want.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, boy.
Kevin Rose: You said it on a private text
to me that you had a couple of drinks with
Attia last night.
Attia is not a big drinker, at all.
Every time I've gone out to dinner with him,
he has one tequila.
Tim Ferriss: I had more than he had.
I had more than Peter.
Kevin Rose: Is he into this ketone thing as
well?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Kevin Rose: Was that what you were drinking
or no?
Tim Ferriss: No, no, no.
We were drinking red wine from Spain, which
was fantastic in the moment.
I love red wine.
I'll continue to have it on occasion.
Maybe I'm just becoming the crypt keeper,
if anybody gets the reference.
You've got to be pretty old already to get
the reference.
My body tolerates wine of any type increasingly
poorly with respect to sleep.
If I have three glasses, man, I feel like
somebody put a pillowcase over my head and
just punched me in the face for like an hour
in the middle of the night.
It's rough.
Kevin Rose: Do you get the hot sweats?
Tim Ferriss: I do, reliably.
And you can track it if you have an Oura ring
or something else on, you look at it, you're
like, "Good lord, what happened to my body
in the middle of the night?"
It is so bad.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, this happens to Daria, too.
She's like a sweaty line backer in the middle
of the night.
It's like you don't want to go near it.t
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's brutal.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, it's a lot.
Tim Ferriss: And I know that's going to happen,
which is why if I'm going to have a drink,
a real drink or otherwise...
I have not found this stuff to help sleep,
by the way.
The R 1,3, as much as I am interested and
I have been, I have boxes of this stuff, and
I'm not an investor, because I'm interested
in how I might use this to moderate ethanol-based
alcohol consumption, which I enjoy.
But let's just say I can pregame with one
of these, get to a point where I'm kind of
loopy.
I will say that one of these compared to one
say tequila soda, the R 1,3 will fuck up my
verbal acuity or my ability to speak much
more than the-
Kevin Rose: Yeah, that's all you're really
looking for.
Tim Ferriss: ... real alcohol.
So it's perfect for this podcast.
Kevin Rose: At the end of the day you just
want to be slurring your words.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, and this stuff also per
can, I have found to throw off your physical
coordination a lot more than an equivalent
single alcohol drink, so you do need to be
careful with it.
It's not something you want to pound and then
grab a chainsaw and go out gathering wood.
Kevin Rose: Well, that's the weird thing is
it's such a non-obvious...
Like I would never have imagined you were
going to say that when you started this podcast,
because typically I think ketones is like,
"Okay, I'm going to chug a bottle pre-workout,"
so I mean I guess you could go lifting right
now, drunk lifting if you wanted to, but-
Tim Ferriss: No, this would be terrible for
performance.
This is bad for performance.
Well, let's put it a different way.
It is not a performance enhancer in the same
way that other ketone supplements might be,
so I have taken...
Even earlier today, I took a different exogenous
ketone supplement because I was eating pretty
low calorie today before recording a podcast
this morning, and it, within 20 minutes or
25 minutes, reliably kicked up my blood ketone
levels as would be measured with, say, a
Kevin Rose: [inaudible 00:10:18] strip or-
Tim Ferriss: Oh, no, the Precision Xtra.
Kevin Rose: [inaudible 00:10:20].
Tim Ferriss: You can use a breathalyzer, you
can use the finger pricks.
I didn't measure it, but reliably I will see
a bump of one to two millimoles, which is
substantial.
And I went from being foggy and tired and
slow to being fast with my words, not having
to search for turns of phrase, everything
was coming quickly.
It was very reliable as a performance enhancer.
This, what I'm drinking, will have the opposite
effect.
Kevin Rose: So actually this is really interesting.
One question for you on that front, Tim, because
I know having traveled with you a ton to countries
where you've been so generous as to be our
translator, where Tim will translate for you
for about six hours and then you'll just shut
down
Tim Ferriss: And then I get so grumpy.
Kevin Rose: You're, "You figure it out.
I'm done translating."
Tim Ferriss: "Google Translate's good enough,
God damn it.
I don't want to do this job anymore."
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
Tim was like our paid translator at one of
my birthday parties for the entire trip.
Unpaid, unpaid.
So I'm curious though, you know mentioned
how quick...
Words just flow like butter.
Would it help in a situation like that, do
you think?
Have you tried it?
Ketones when translating?
Tim Ferriss: For translating, I'm sure it
would help if you're using the right class
of ketone.
Because when we're talking about ketones,
you have ketone esters, you have ketone salts,
and I'm not qualified to talk about the intricate
science of it all.
Someone like Dr. Dominic Agostino, who I've
had on the podcast at least twice, is one
of the preeminent researchers in the space
who also works with...
I want to say the Department of Defense, might
be DARPA, in synthesizing compounds for special
forces and [inaudible 00:12:12].
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I was going to say weren't
the Seals using it at some point?
Tim Ferriss: Right, and so they need measurable
benefit, and one of the measurable benefits
is that it helps you to sustain physical and
cognitive performance under conditions of
low oxygen, which you might experience if
you're doing, say, extended deep diving or
submersion, which you might also experience
if you're at altitude.
So recently, this would've been early October,
I used ketones to help acclimate to altitude
and then tapered off of the ketones so I wouldn't
perhaps prevent some of the physiological
adaptations that I would want to sustain without
using ketones every day.
So they're fascinating.
I will say, if I'm taking the other side of
the argument and making a counter case, I
am skeptical that taking exogenous ketones
constantly when you are consuming a normal
diet, which is relatively rich in carbohydrates...
So your blood glucose is not necessarily pathologically
elevated, but if your glucose is normally
elevated and then you have very elevated blood
ketone levels, my understanding is that does
not readily occur in nature, at least with
humans in an organic capacity, unless you
are in a dangerous position as a diabetic
where you're experiencing keto acidosis, which
can be fatal.
I mean it's very, very precarious.
So my feeling is, if this doesn't occur in
nature, because normally you'd be producing
ketones in a state of starvation even though...
I should be clear.
We're producing ketones a lot of the time
but in trivial amounts.
By the time we get to the point where we're
noticing it and we're breaking down meaningful
body fat in order to produce these alternate
sources of energy, which the heart and the
brain really love.
The heart and the brain really like ketones.
Kevin Rose: Do they prefer them over carbohydrate?
Is that right?
Or glucose?
Tim Ferriss: I've heard that said.
I don't have that much difficulty believing
it from a first person perspective.
When I've done extended fasts, especially,
the ketones provoked...
Maybe it's just the spectrum of changes provoked
by fasting, say on day two or three where
my ketones will naturally be in the 1.5 to
2.5 millimolar range.
That condition feels different and I feel
sharper than I do when I use exogenous ketones,
supplemental ketones, to get to the same measurement
using a single device.
And I'm not sure why that is, but it feels
different.
You feel much sharper when you get there through
fasting, in my experience.
And that is to say, not all ketones are created
equal so this right here is going to make
you slur your words and shit the bed from
a performance perspective, but might be fun
as an experimental ethanol replacement.
And then there are others.
There are many different options out there
that are documented for performing, excuse
me...
Documented, there go the words, documented
for improving performance.
Kevin Rose: So one question for you, Tim,
and we can move on to all the whole slew of
topics that we have otherwise this will be
a two-hour ketone episode, but I'm curious
when people are listening, there's no doubt
right now a lot of people are like, "Okay,
this sounds crazy, this sounds kind of fun.
Maybe I want to try this."
You've already mentioned the drink.
What about if you're just doing it for mental
performance?
The one brand that I know had licensed the
patents from somewhere in England was it HVM,
HVMN?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, HVMN-
Kevin Rose: You what I'm talking about?
Tim Ferriss: I do.
I believe that they are very focused on this
particular type of ketone, the R 1,3.
I don't want to say that with great conviction,
but I would say to everyone, you owe it to
yourself because you're putting something
in your body that
could have a significant impact on your blood
chemistry and your entire biological system.
Read a few studies, find out what the exact
ketone is and go on PubMed or somewhere else
and just read at least a few abstracts.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, but we just want to know
what you're taking, dude.
Just tell us the brand.
What are you juicing up with in the morning?
What am I juicing up with?
Here, hold on...
Like what did you take before the podcast.
What's the brand-
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'll grab it.
I'll grab it.
Hold on a second.
Kevin Rose: Okay, okay.
I'll entertain you all while Tim is gone.
So what Tim doesn't know is we've secretly
replaced his ketones with diabetic horse urine.
Tim Ferriss: I love it.
Exactly.
So this right here, you know what the details
are not...
The specifics are not on the back of this.
It's on the back of the larger box.
The label does not scream scientific credibility
but it's a fun label.
So this right here...
It's going to be a little hard to see.
The label reads KetoneAid, that is the brand
SnakeWater, ketone ester plus electrolytes.
So it's ketone ester plus electrolytes.
The brand name is KetoneAid, one word, SnakeWater.
I want to be super clear though, because I
think people can fuck themselves up with these
things, I am not a doctor.
I do not play one on The Random Show or on
the internet.
Do your reading and talk to your doctor because
there are people for which something like
this would be contraindicated.
So pay attention, folks.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I mean, never take a supplement
from the man that created CØCKPUNCH.
That's just fair to say.
Tim Ferriss: I think those are very wise words.
Yeah, yeah, furthermore, just as a side note,
I want to say I love when I'm talking to someone...
And especially in Austin, you can't throw
a rock without hitting someone who wants to
tell you about their latest ayahuasca experience.
It's just like you can't escape it, and if
you're at a group dinner something will come
up related to psychedelics.
You cannot avoid it in Austin, which rubs
me the wrong way sometimes but I guess I contributed
to it probably in some way, so there you go.
Just desserts.
But the point I wanted to make is you're having
a group dinner and somebody will say, "I really
don't do drugs, I just drink," and I'm like,
"Oh, you mean the civilization destroyer?
That's the only one that you use?
It's a drug, it's a drug.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I mean to pretend alcohol
is...
It's just, yeah, totally.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, come on-
Kevin Rose: I was just going to say, anything
you put in your body that provokes a change,
that's a drug.
Banana, ketone, tequila.
Tim Ferriss: For sure.
Kevin Rose: Prescription medication.
They're all drugs.
Tim Ferriss: Every time I talk to Attia about
alcohol or anyone on his team, they're just
like, "Don't do it."
Kevin Rose: "It's so bad.
"
Tim Ferriss: "It's the worst.
It's so bad for you."
I'm like-
Kevin Rose: And yet, and yet, here we are.
Tim Ferriss: Sometimes you just want to have
a drink.
Kevin Rose: That's right.
Tim Ferriss: Sometimes you just want to have
a drink.
Speaking of which, let's move into the show.
So New Year's resolutions, what do you have,
Kevin?
And is there anything that's been on there
for like five years straight and you're bringing
it up?
Kevin Rose: Oh, we can go back.
Tim Ferriss: We have at least five years of
Random shows that we could probably do a flashback
to every single failed one.
Kevin Rose: All the failed resolutions.
Tim Ferriss: That'd be an amazing montage.
Oh, my god, there'd be so many.
Kevin Rose: So I would say...
I want to hear yours as well.
I'll do a rapid fire on mine, and if you feel
like digging in deeper on any of them, you're
welcome to.
So I mean the no-brainer is just not drinking
in January, that's a no brainer, just a good
reset-
Tim Ferriss: Have you done that before?
Kevin Rose: Yeah, kind of.
Tim Ferriss: That was a little, so so hand
signal we got.
Kevin Rose: No, I mean it depends on how many
months or how many...
Tim Ferriss: Oh, boy.
Kevin Rose: It depends on how you define January
so-
Tim Ferriss: The witness is getting uncomfortable.
He's sweating, starting to shift around.
Kevin Rose: Listen, I just got back from a
seven-day silent meditation retreat.
I did not do any alcohol and so I take-
Tim Ferriss: You're a paragon of self-control.
You didn't get hammered on your meditation
retreat.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: So question for you, if you're
not going to drink...
I know this.
People may not know this.
Flying makes you super, super nervous, as
far as I remember.
He really doesn't like flying.
Kevin Rose: [inaudible 00:21:16] in the sky.
[inaudible 00:21:18] do it.
It doesn't make sense.
Tim Ferriss: So when Kevin flies, Kev-Kev
tends to have a drink or two or three.
Kevin Rose: I mean, I like a glass of champagne,
you know?
It's like there's nothing wrong with it.
Tim Ferriss: We can pretend that's what we're
going to-
Kevin Rose: No, you're right.
So here's the deal.
I'll give you an example.
Tim Ferriss: So would you have to cut back
on your travel for a booze-free January?
Kevin Rose: No, no, no.
I'm not that bad anymore.
So when I flew back from the meditation retreat,
I didn't drink, which is great.
Tim Ferriss: Did you take a handful of Xanax
though?
Tell me the truth.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, exactly.
No I didn't.
I was fine.
I was totally fine.
And-
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Kevin Rose: Look at that.
Tim Ferriss: Go meditation
Kevin Rose: It's one of those things where
I don't know what it is.
You know what it is about flying?
This is going to sound ridiculous.
I'm not flying the plane.
I want to be in control and I kind of want
to fly it, but I don't know how so that doesn't
make sense either.
So it's a very confusing thing and it's something
that is just...
We all got our things.
I'm sure you have some.
Tim Ferriss: I got plenty of things.
Kevin Rose: [inaudible 00:22:20] a good one.
I haven't unpacked this with you ever.
You're Tim-Tim the fearless.
You do all kinds of crazy shit.
What's the one thing that people wouldn't
know that scares you?
[inaudible 00:22:32] some shit.
Tim Ferriss: Terrified of heights.
Kevin Rose: Are you serious?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, and so when I go rock climbing,
I do this as a way to try to inoculate myself
against some of the fear, to the extent that
if I get to a height that many people, even
up in a tree like 15 feet, something like
that, my legs will start to shake.
I'm very afraid of heights.
And when I rock climb, I'll be belaying somebody,
let's just say it and it's my turn to go,
before I am even on the wall, I have sweat
pouring off my hands.
So I end up using...
I can't just use chalk because it turns into
this sticky mud on my hands and if I go up
a wall, even if it's a small wall, let's say
it's a 50-foot wall, I'll have to reapply
chalk like five times.
So what I will do...
People might find this useful.
There's a product called Rhino.
It probably has another word there, but Rhino,
basically antiperspirant for your hands used
by some competitive rock climbers.
And that is the only thing...
it was recommended to me by a professional
level climber... that has helped.
And I am fairly sure...
Sorry company, it's a great product.
If you're constantly inhibiting perspiration
through the hands, I have to imagine there
may be side effects, I would think, so I haven't
used it all the time.
But if I'm training, let's just say, as I
would like to...
This will come back to the resolutions, I
guess, but train at least twice a week, three
times a week, for a period of time, why not?
If I did that three, four weeks on, one week
off and did that for a quarter, it'd be hard
for me to imagine that would do a lot of damage,
but I am very afraid of heights.
To answer your question.
Kevin Rose: Have you ever done the VR thing
where you walk out on the plank and it's like
you're up a 15-story building or 20-story
building?
Tim Ferriss: I have.
I'm actually, for whatever reason, fine with
that.
Maybe it's because it's not convincing enough
yet or the kinesthetic feedback isn't quite
there yet, or the depth perception is quite
not there yet from an adaptive eye tracking
perspective when you're using-
Kevin Rose: Would you ever bungee jump?
Tim Ferriss: I have bungee jumped before.
Kevin Rose: That's weird.
Tim Ferriss: And it scared the shit out of
me and I wanted to do it in part because it
was going to scare the shit out of me, and
I did it off a bridge in Taiwan.
This is forever ago.
And everyone was going backwards and they
were kind of falling butt first and I was
like, "All right, I want to get tied up and
I want to jump off head first looking straight
down as I'm going."
And I did it and it scared the shit out of
me but I will say, despite all of this exposure,
so if this were, I guess it's what, prolonged
exposure PE therapy?
It does not seem to have reduced my fear of
heights at all, whatsoever and-
Kevin Rose: That's crazy.
I had no idea.
That's new for me.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah.
That's a real thing.
Kevin Rose: It's interesting, the more I fly-
Tim Ferriss: Just talking about it...
I kid you not, the more...
I'm just talking about heights right now and
my hands are sweating.
Kevin Rose: So I've done a lot of...
You know this.
I've done a lot of rock climbing and did it
a bunch in my youth and I think that the sweating
thing would happen to me, as well, but not
to the point...
But that's just natural.
You're just like, you're going up a wall,
especially if you're lead climbing and you're
clipping in as you're going, it's much scarier.
But yeah, I didn't know they made antiperspirant
your hands though.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, they do.
I'll look it up, but keep going on your...
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
All right, so-
Tim Ferriss: So January, booze free.
Booze free means no booze?
Kevin Rose: That's right, no drinks.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Rose: Wine is fine, but everything else
is out.
Tim Ferriss: What?
Wine is fine?
What kind of- [inaudible 00:26:40].
Oh, my god.
Amazing.
Kevin Rose: Moving on, so the sad thing...
So I have a WHOOP on and Apple Watch on and
I've tested all these devices, and I really
do enjoy playing with them and trying all
the latest software out, and one of the things
that is really disappointing to me is in the
last year, actually a couple years now since
COVID, Apple Watch will have a cardio fitness
level built inside of it and mine's been slowly
going down and I'm like, "Ah, shit.
This sucks.
I got to get back into shape."
My dad died of a heart attack, my grandpa
died of a heart attack.
Cardiovascular issues are not new to my family
so, for me, this is a big deal.
So I'm really focused on cardiovascular fitness
for this new year.
A couple of things just to let people know
where I'm at.
I've tried out all the different latest versions
of software for fitness tracking.
I'd like to link this up in your show notes.
There's a scientist on YouTube called the
Quantified Scientist that I really like.
He's awesome.
He basically uses a lot of the gold standard
ways to track sleep and he'll hook himself
up to all the real professional devices and
then also use the consumer devices and say,
"How good are these devices?
How accurate are they at really predicting
the levels of sleep?
How good are they at heart rate detection
while jogging?
Is Oura any good because it's moving around
on your finger all the time."
There's all these open questions, and all
he does...
I think it's his full-time job now... is just
put out new videos with all the latest fitness
trackers and tell you if they're any good
and a lot of them are crap.
Tim Ferriss: That's a cool niche, though,
that he's basically saying-
Kevin Rose: Yeah, it's a really cool niche.
Tim Ferriss: He's like, "All right, we're
going to look at hydrostatic underwater weighing
for body composition and compare it to whatever
this thing is you're wearing."
If we take it as...
I think I'm getting that description right,
but if we take this underwater approach as
the, say, Olympic gold standard, how do these
things stack up?
That's cool.
Kevin Rose: Right, exactly, exactly.
Yeah, it's really cool.
And so the TLDR is that the Apple Watch is
actually pretty damn good now.
It didn't always used to be, but it's really
good for heart rate and it's really good for
sleep.
The WHOOP I like because...
It's not as good as the Apple Watch, but what
it does is it does activity-specific tracking,
so for example...
And yes, you can do that on the Apple Watch
too.
You can say, "I'm doing elliptical," or, "I'm
doing all this stuff," but the WHOOP is cool
because you can say, "Okay, I'm going to sit
down.
I'm going to do a meditation."
It'll detect that you're doing that and then
it'll give you your heart rate in real time,
or it'll show you the graph after you're done
over that activity, and it's much harder to
try and find that data.
Apple, their device is amazing, their software
kind of sucks.
Like health kit and the whole health interface,
it's not a consumer app.
It's very clinical feeling.
So the data's there, but it's not represented
in the right way, if that makes sense.
So anyway, long story short, Oura has a brand
new sleep algorithm.
The Quantified Scientists have yet to test
that out against all those other things.
Their sleep algorithm, I think, was pretty
screwed up before, but they're testing a new
one now.
You can enable it in beta so I'm going to
wait and see how that goes for sleep tracking.
But anyway, my methods for cardio, Peloton
Rower.
I'm not involved in Peloton in any way, don't
have any stock but I saw the new rower and
it looks pretty interesting.
So they give you a 30-day money back guarantee.
I just bought it.
It'll show up in the next couple of days.
I think that's good.
They say rowing is 80% of your muscles, which
is amazing, all at the same time, so if you're
looking for a quick hit, like 15, 20-minute
workout...
I don't know, I'm excited about it.
I'm going to give it a shot.
Tim Ferriss: I can hop in for a second.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, please.
Tim Ferriss: So I had a chance to test the
Peloton Rower for the first time, and this
is part of due diligence because I have been
having conversations with Peloton, and you
didn't know this before putting together-
Kevin Rose: No.
Tim Ferriss: ... the prep for this conversation.
Kevin Rose: This is the first I'm hearing
of it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, so Peloton and I have been
talking about possibly doing something in
terms of sponsorship on the podcast related
to the rower, and as is my first step with
all of these things, I asked to use a unit,
I said I have to test it.
And I had the chance to test a unit.
This would've been, I don't know, two or three
weeks ago.
And I was very impressed with it.
And I can give you a couple of tips that might
help other people who are also getting the
units.
So the first is the form correction is very
helpful, and almost everyone will use their
arms too much, lean back too far, and use
their legs incorrectly.
Kevin Rose: So I don't know what the form
correction is, it's just like in the software
or something like-
Tim Ferriss: It is in the software.
So it will show a profile of you on the rower
and it will flash red in areas where you need
to correct the form-
Kevin Rose: How does it know to break?
The front camera?
Tim Ferriss: Sensors in the seat and sensors
on the pulling mechanism.
And there are probably other sensors on top
of that.
And the feedback is actually quite helpful.
There is a competitive or former competitive,
I think he's still current competitive rower,
very large white guy who has excellent form.
And there are other instructors who have excellent
form, but he is the instructor who I know,
and I'm blanking on his name, people could
figure it out, who has a competitive background.
And the reason that's attractive to me is
if you are going to be a competitive rower
in the long term and succeed-
Kevin Rose: No injuries.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
If your technique is not efficient, you are
going to suffer from repetitive use injuries,
100%, and debilitate you.
So I like the idea of modeling, at least in
the beginning stages, the technique on someone
who has competitive experience.
So that would be a recommendation.
I apologize, I'm blanking on his name.
The last thing I would say, and I've provided
feedback, product feedback, so we'll see,
since I think they could make modifications
quite easily with firmware instead of changing
the hardware.
And if my experience with the Peloton bike
is any indication, they will make constant
firmware improvements.
So I expect by the time I'm even saying this,
that once you get your shipped unit, I'm hoping
there may be some modifications made.
The sensors at the very back of the seat are
very sensitive.
So my experience was, you may get a bit too
much feedback in terms of a red alert indicating
you're leaning back when you may not in fact
be leaning back that far.
So two suggestions, and these are my experiential
suggestions, not any type of, I don't think
official suggestion.
Scoot your butt forward just a little bit
so that it's not all the way at the back of
the seat.
Second is absolutely focus on not leaning
back excessively.
And so I do think as a practice, especially
for engaging your legs, it's good to almost
lean forward slightly as you do the exercise.
And what blew my mind is once I had the technique
feedback, once I had the guidance in terms
of exertion and some metrics to watch, I found
that I could do longer rowing workouts.
I could actually do a long rowing workouts.
And I have a concept two rower, and I like
the concept two rower.
But what I found is without any of those feedback
mechanisms, I would crank up the resistance
because there's a resistance style on the
concept two, crank up the resistance, and
I would go balls to the wall for 500 meters
and I would effectively be done.
My heart rate would be through the roof.
My arms would be sore, my legs would not be
sore, and I was roasted.
I could go longer.
But if I were trying to do something, let's
just say as a short morning workout, 500 to
750 meters.
And I was like, okay, I think that at this
point my biceps are the weak link in the chain
using the Peloton rower and following the
feedback easily could do a 30 to 45-minute
workout, which better engaged all of the musculature
that you were aiming to engage.
So I had a very positive experience, very
positive experience, and I'm sure that they
will of course.
And they already, I'm sure, have many plans
to iterate on the firmware.
So I think you'll enjoy it.
I'll be curious to hear your thoughts.
Now, I will say, since you gave a peek behind
the scenes earlier, I'll do you the same favor.
When you send me those naked mirror selfie
shots, post-workout every once in a while-
Kevin Rose: Which I always do, you love them
too.
Tim Ferriss: I'll get one of these from Kevin.
Kevin Rose: Send me Apple Cash right after,
and I appreciate it.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, it's great.
It's great.
Yeah, I did upgrade to premium on your OnlyFans,
and I always get the tricep shot.
And you have good triceps.
I always get the tricep shot.
It's not still there.
I still got it.
It's not frequent.
It's not frequent that I get the quad or the
calf flex.
Kevin Rose: I have good quads now.
Tim Ferriss: I don't get this.
What?
Kevin Rose: Well, they're getting better.
I've been doing a lot of squats.
I'll send you some updated pics.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, oh, great.
Great.
Good, good, good.
Fantastic.
Yeah, I was just going to ensure that you
understand that using a rower involves your
legs.
I just wanted to make sure that those-
Kevin Rose: No, you know what's funny is,
all jokes aside, Tim, seriously, in the last
four weeks I've really focused on my legs,
and I'm enjoying it a lot.
It's like I don't know but, so I've always
hate abs, I still hate abs.
There's nothing about abs that I'm ever going
to love.
But once you actually start to build up your
legs, there's like this...
I mean, it's like with anything fitness related,
there's this painful first few weeks.
And if you can cross that chasm and kind of
get on the other side of it, I don't know,
things are looking up on the legs.
Tim Ferriss: And also you just feel a lot
better.
You feel a lot stronger, you feel much more
stable when you're doing that kind of work.
And I don't want to interrupt your flow on
the New Year stuff, but I have some physical
resolutions-
Kevin Rose: Jump in.
Tim Ferriss: ... as well.
Kevin Rose: Why not?
We can jump back to mine.
Let's just keep it going.
Pop on it around as they call it.
Tim Ferriss: So I am going to be spending
most of January and February focusing on skiing.
I find skiing to be a perfect blend of some
of my favorite things.
And I have done snowboarding.
I just tend to injure myself immediately because
snowboarding comes very naturally.
I still think I'm a 15-year-old skateboarder
and I start doing stuff at the park and getting
fancy and then I injure myself, inevitably.
So rather than try to rely on restraint, which
is not my strong suit, I just don't allow
myself to snowboard anymore.
Skiing is a wonderful combination of time
and nature, being outside, moving with speed
under control, where you get an adrenaline
hit, but ideally without excessive danger.
It is subtle, and you can refine technique
for a long time and not run out of room to
improve.
You can make quantum leaps in your performance
with proper instruction.
Kevin Rose: And you can do it when you're
70 too.
People can-
Tim Ferriss: And you can do it when you are
older.
And that has become so much more important
for me.
And to this end though I am, or both in process
and leading up to it.
So let's just say I have actually not that
much time.
I have 10 days, so I'm not going to do a whole
lot of conditioning in the next 10 days.
But I have done some leading up to it focusing
on lower body, lower leg.
As you know, I've had so many injuries, so
I've torn most of the connective tissue, the
meaningful connective tissue in my ankles
over the years just from the outrageous decisions
and bad commitments with combat sports and
getting heel hooked and things like this.
So I, as a result, need to compensate by strengthening
the lower legs on the lateral portion, the
rear of my calf, everything to try to compensate
for weak ankles and terrible torso flexion.
And-
Kevin Rose: Is that your weak point if someone
wanted to take you out is just go for your
ankles?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you got to go for the ankles.
Kevin Rose: Just curious.
Tim Ferriss: It is a weak spot.
So yeah, you can go for the ankles.
If someone wants to come at me, go for the
ankles and I'll just pull out my concealed
carriage and shoot you in the face anyway.
Kevin Rose: [Inaudible 00:40:07] punch floor
price, just go for his ankles.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, if you go for the ankles,
just be prepared.
I may be packing.
So there's that.
And the reason I bring all of this up though
is that it's one thing for me to make commitment
in say an urban environment to improve lower
body strength and to work on stability.
And to do so in a way that is sort of clinical
in a workout without real world engagement.
But if I really want to stack the deck in
my favor to accomplish that, I want to set
the environment.
And I want to set my social interactions in
such a way that that goal is served.
And I recognize this is a very fortunate position
that I'm in, but I do think people can borrow
this maybe framework or way of looking at
goals to think about.
All right, I say I want to do X, how can I
optimize spending time with people who will
help me achieve X, or who are already achieving
X, or are trying to achieve X?
How can I put myself in locations where I
am more likely to interact with those people
and absorb some of these maybe ancillary habits
related to my primary goal through sheer exposure.
Kevin Rose: So Tim tells that, I think that
is such a very, very important thing.
This idea that the sum of your closest friends
largely makes up what you're into, your hobbies,
the things you get excited about.
When you find there's something new you want
to go after, let's call it skiing or something.
You're lucky because you can pick up the phone
and world class skiers will answer and say,
let me take you out for the day.
So you're Tim Ferriss.
But how do you recommend that people going
into the new year, if there's something new
they want to get into, or they look around
at their friend group and they're just like,
this isn't helping me get to the next level.
What do you do if you're stuck like that?
Tim Ferriss: Go make some new friends.
And I would say furthermore let's-
Kevin Rose: Friendster.
Tim Ferriss: Friendster.
So aside from Friendster, I will say, and
I'll mention this, I don't mention it that
much.
The 4-Hour Chef confusingly is actually a
book about accelerated learning and skill
acquisition.
I talk a lot about this in The 4-Hour Chef.
So even if you buy it, you don't give a shit
about cooking, and you just want to learn
about meta learning and acquiring physical
skills, there's a section called meta learning
in The 4-Hour Chef.
And I highly recommend that people dig into
it because the recommendations work.
And I've used them dozens of times now.
One of the points that I make is if you go
on Google and search whatever your target
sport is, let's just for the time being assume-
Kevin Rose: I want to play that pickle sport.
Tim Ferriss: Pickleball?
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I haven't tried that yet.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, pickleball is fun.
Pickleball is fun.
It's more ankle friendly than tennis, but
you can still roll an ankle or two if you're
not careful.
So it is exciting.
Austin is also not only the third coast capital
of ayahuasca and unending ayahuasca conversations,
but also pickleball.
There's a lot of pickleball here.
And in sort of Central Valley, California,
it's become very popular.
But putting pickleball aside for a second,
because that is not yet an Olympic sport.
Let's say you want to get better at a sport
that is a professional sport, or I should
say amateur or professional sport represented
in the Olympics.
Could be swimming, could be skiing, could
be just about anything, snowboarding, et cetera.
If you search for snowboard silver medalist,
bronze medalist, or even maybe gold medalist
from two Olympics ago, there's a very good
chance, and this is not to minimize their
achievement, but the fact of the matter is
there are many sports that are financially
rewarded in the US, basketball, baseball,
and there are many that are not.
And I don't think that's fair in sense.
It's not reflective of the dedication or skill
necessary to be good at certain things.
Gymnastics would be another one.
However, that does mean an opportunity for
a lot of people.
And you could find a silver medalist or a
bronze medalist who by the way, in many cases
is just a gold medalist who had a bad day.
That's it.
And you could get one-on-one remote or in-person
training with them in many cases for a hundred
bucks an hour.
And I realized-
Kevin Rose: That's amazing.
I haven't thought about that.
Yeah.
Any medal is fine, like bronze, copper, whatever.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you don't need, also, if
you are...
I mean, I am not the best skier, but I do
ski black diamond, I've done some hell skiing
and I've done a lot of off piece, kind of
off terrain.
I'm not a great skier, but I have a basic
foundation of ability.
I do not need a gold medalist.
I need someone who is substantially better
than I am.
And this is very key.
And who can teach.
Because in many cases you'll find, say a college
coach, maybe they're retired, doesn't really
matter, in a given sport who will be a far
better instructor and get you further ahead
than a gold medalist.
If that gold medalist has never really taught.
Everything they've done since age five has
become second nature.
So they can't explicitly name or describe
what they're doing.
So you have a broad menu of people you can
choose from if you're trying to learn a new
skill.
And it is so mind bendingly affordable in
so many cases.
There's so many fields.
Let's take an example.
I am very excited about archery.
So some of my goals relate to archery for
the new year, and I've been taking it seriously
for a while.
I feel very comfortable with compound.
I'm focusing now on recurve and bare bow which
is-
Kevin Rose: Are you better than Attia or is
Attia better than you because he's in there
as well.
Tim Ferriss: I don't know.
I don't know.
I've no idea.
I mean, Attia has gone full with archery.
He's making his own materials-
Kevin Rose: He's better than you.
Tim Ferriss: .... fletching.
Well then, he might be.
Then, he might be, I am feel very confident
in my ability to do what I have tasked myself
with doing with respect-
Kevin Rose: We got into bareback riding a
long time ago, that archery, remember that?
You were doing bareback archery in Japan.
Tim Ferriss: It is not bareback, but I was
doing yabusame horseback archery in Japan
with traditional bows that are long bows,
about six feet long.
Where you-
Kevin Rose: Is there a saddle on that horse
or no?
Tim Ferriss: There's a saddle, but the saddle
is very, very thin wood.
The only purpose of the saddle is to hor hold
the stirrups on the horse so you can ride
the horse without sitting on the horse.
So you're effectively doing a wide squat in
the stirrups.
The only purpose of the saddle is to hold
you on the horse.
And the saddle is not intended to be sat upon.
I have two antique saddles at home-
Kevin Rose: I know.
I've seen those.
Tim Ferriss: ... that were my reward.
Those were my first real reward I gave myself
in any meaningful way for anything I did.
And it was for The 4-Hour Body hitting number
one New York Times.
That's why I have the saddles.
Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And so, gosh, Tim, we've known
each other a long time, man.
Tim Ferriss: Super long time.
Kevin Rose: I remember walking in, what was
that downstairs place that you had, you went
down this hallway to Tim's house and it was
like there was a big huge Japanese, you had
the full armor, right?
Off to the light.
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
I had the armor.
Kevin Rose: What was that?
Little kendo you had or something?
Tim Ferriss: So the armor had traveled with
me for quite a while.
This was kendo armor that I used in Japan.
Kevin Rose: A kendo you had in San Francisco
with that little...
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it was on the right hand
side.
So as you walked in, it was in two different
places.
One place I rented, and then another place
that I bought.
And the place that I bought, which was in
Glen Park, I guess both of them were in Glen
Park.
The first one had this hallway leading in,
pretty long hallway, and it was all kettlebells.
It was all kettlebells.
It was just like 20 kettlebells.
And then you walk up and the armor was to
the right.
It was directly to the right, across this
walkway that went from the living room into
the kitchen.
And the armor was directly on the right when
you came into the place that I bought later.
You'd walk in and on the left hand side was
an entire chalkboard wall that had artwork
on it.
So it was like 12 feet of chalk art, which
was incredible.
So good.
I was so impressed with this artist.
And then on the right hand side had the Japanese
armor.
And that was the kendo armor I used when I
was in Japan.
Kevin Rose: Tim's house back then was exactly...
Because I met you and you just launched the
4-Hour Workweek.
It was just the launch party.
It was when I met you for that.
And I remember I came to your house, and I
remembered just walking at some point to hang
out, and I didn't know you that well.
And it was just like you walked on this aisle
of kettlebells.
It was like a hall of kettlebells, and then
this Japanese armor and weird saddles and
maybe the saddles were later I think.
Tim Ferriss: Saddles were few years later,
yeah.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
And then there was books all over the place
with all these little note things in them.
And I'm just like, this guy is crazy.
Tim Ferriss: The honeymoon phase of our friendship.
Kevin Rose: That's right.
Tim Ferriss: Kettlebell date.
So yeah, I suppose taking a long roundabout
way of saying, do not assume that you do not
have access to really good teachers, it's
right there.
But people don't look for it because they
assume that it's not.
And this type of outreach and finding instructors
I did well before I ever had the first book.
And you can do it.
There are very direct ways to do it as particularly
if you know the right questions to ask, you
need to know the right questions to ask.
It is your job to use the instructor like
the niche expert Google you want them to be,
to provide feedback.
You have to know how to be proactive as a
student.
And if you learn how to do that, you also
remove one of the requirements I gave.
And that is you can take someone who is not
experienced in teaching and make them a good
teacher by virtue of feeding in the right
questions.
And I don't want to sound like I'm hitting
it too hard because frankly I make next to
nothing on these books.
But the 4-Hour Chef meta learning section
has all of this.
It's very in depth.
So I encourage people to check it out.
Kevin Rose: Awesome.
Very cool.
Tim Ferriss: What else you got?
Kevin Rose: You can do a couple more resolutions
or?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, let's do it.
I've shifted into fifth gear, and I'm making
the transition to the [inaudible 00:52:18].
Just FYI.
Kevin Rose: I'm on my second and a half class,
so it's going to get interesting real quick
here.
All right, so a few more things on my list
and then we can move.
I want to talk to you about your NFT ventures
and figure out how that's going.
So I finished my seven-day very first ever
Zen meditation retreat.
It was fantastic in so many ways.
And I would say that the one thing that it
gave me is when you sit for eight hours of
meditation per day, you realize very quickly
that the 25 minutes is actually nothing, it
just is nothing.
And it has really, really helped me create
since returning from that trip, I had just
haven't missed a day, and it's just been solid.
Because it feels like it's so trivial, it's
like of course I can find 25 minutes to go
and sit, or do a double sit in a day and get
to 50 or 55 if you're doing walking along
with it.
But it just reframed that entire thing for
me, which I think is fantastic.
And it also gave me this sense of just knowing
I want to go deeper in this realm.
And the experience of the community and at
the Zendo and everyone getting together.
You've been on one of these.
And I know yours was a little bit rocky, I'd
be curious to see if you'd go back to one,
but I had a fantastic time in.
So I know meditation is going to be top priority
and of all the things that I do going into
next year.
Tim Ferriss: So let me ask some follow ups.
I will say that I would be open to doing something
like that again.
I would probably try a different format.
So at the time I'd done a Vipassana silent
retreat, and the sitting was similarly intensive
and the vast majority of your day is sitting
or walking meditation, mostly sitting.
And I've told that story before so I won't
tell it here.
If people want to hear that, and effectively
it gets into some very heavy stuff so I won't
rehash it here.
But if you want to hear the story, I told
it on 10% Happier, the podcast with Dan Harris.
And we got into it quite a bit.
I had effectively a full psychotic unraveling
at my extended meditation retreat, which relates
to a bunch of childhood trauma and abuse and
so on.
So it's not what I would consider family listening,
but if people want background, they can listen
to that.
And it ended up being a very important experience
for me, but it also scared the shit out of
me.
And I was very worried about being in a psychological
free fall.
And thank God Jack Kornfield, who has been
on this podcast a number of times, who is
an extremely masterful and skilled teacher,
meditator, who is clinical psychologist, has
worked with veterans, adolescents who cut,
he has an extremely hybridized toolkit, which
makes him very, very, very effective.
And he walks the walk.
That guy is as legit as it comes.
So people may also want to listen to the podcast
I've done with him.
I would be open to testing another format
though.
And I've been extremely impressed with Henry
Shukman, who is your Jedi master as I understand
it.
And-
Kevin Rose: He's amazing.
He's been on your podcast twice now, highly
recommended to go back and listen.
Tim Ferriss: He has, and I wanted to thank
you for that introduction.
You had recommended it.
And he's outstanding.
He is a very, very good teacher.
He's a compelling speaker.
And I could see delving into a different format
to see what that provides.
And I'm not in a rush to do it.
I am, however, feeling some urgency to begin
meditating again.
I've completely fallen off the horse.
And so that has been at the very top of my
list.
And I continue to find excuses to put it off.
And it's funny because this happens to me
once every year or two where I'll be meditating,
meditating, meditating, and then suddenly
it's like the excuse factory took a vacation
for a year and then it's like, "I'm back."
And all of a sudden I fall off the horse and
I stop.
And it does not take a lot for me to feel
tremendous benefits.
I would say if I do.
And my default for kickstarting this tends
to be a concentration practice like transcendental
meditation.
I just find it to be the easiest way to get
back on the horse-
Kevin Rose: That mantra base is easy like
that.
It's good.
It's good like that.
Tim Ferriss: Using something like that or
if I want to make it an even easier on-ramp
using say the introduction or the introductory
course with the Waking Up app and Sam Harris,
I find that to be extremely well done.
It provides you with very discreet and cumulative
tools as you go through it.
Really anything to get you into the habit.
And I'll actually bring up something from
a conversation I just had this week with James
Clear.
So James Clear wrote a book called Atomic
Habits-
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I know James.
Tim Ferriss: ... sold 10 million plus copies.
Habits are his thing.
And he shared something with me, a phrasing
that I found very powerful and very memorable.
And I'm going to paraphrase here, I don't
want to speak for him.
But he effectively said something along the
lines of, "When in doubt, keep the schedule,
reduce the scope."
Which means, let's say you've made a commitment
to work out one hour every Monday in the gym.
You're going to do leg day every Monday.
And maybe it's not a 60-minute commitment,
it's just I will do my leg workout every Monday.
And your leg workout as it's currently outlined
takes 45 minutes.
But then life happens, shit happens.
Who knows?
The kid's got a bloody nose, the work call
runs over.
And you look at your watch and you realize,
"Uh-oh, I'm only going to have 15 minutes
to do leg day."
You have a few options at that point.
And the option that I've taken with meditation
is I don't have enough time, I'm not going
to meditate.
And his point is, even if leg day is a warmup
on the rower and some body weight split squats,
that's better than nothing.
And the momentum and the consistency matters.So
for let's just say meditation, if I were to
take that advice, which I have not been, although
I just had this conversation with him yesterday
or the day before.
Even if you sit down and meditate for 30 seconds,
just check the box, sit down and do it, so
that you can build the confidence to maintain
some degree of momentum.
And this applies to diet too.
I think we've all had the experience of being
on some type of diet and maybe you had a little
bit too much to drink, or maybe you ate a
little too many edibles.
And you're like, "I just want a cookie."
And you eat one cookie, "Well, since I had
one cookie, well, I already screwed myself
so let me eat a whole box of cookies."
And the reverse of that is, "Well, I already
have too little time to get a proper meditation
session, and let me do no meditation."
And his point is, stick to the schedule, reduce
the scope.
And I think that's very powerful and I'm going
to try to, I'm going to commit, let me make
a different statement.
I'm going to commit to applying that to meditation
in the new year.
Kevin Rose: That's awesome.
I'd love to hear that because that can snowball
into some bigger things down the road.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally.
Totally.
Kevin Rose: Well, we can move on from meditation
because it's pretty boring topic, but it's
literally just sitting there doing nothing.
But I would say the one thing that I...
So I was very fortunate that, you've been
to my Page Street apartment back in the day
in SF.
I lived right next to the San Francisco Zen
Center, right next to it, literally across
the street.
So, well I took my first Zen course at that
Zen center back 15 years ago.
And I would say that forever, I was doing
the calm slash...
well, Headspace was my first app experience
on meditation.
And I was doing the 10 or 15-minute meditations,
and I did that consistently pretty well, not
seven days a week, but four to five days a
week.
And it gave me just some nice moments to just
kind of, aah, I'm just going to rest a little
bit.
But I got to say there's something even more
special if you can just push into the next
zone of that, 25, 50 minutes.
And they call this word samariam.
I'm sure you've probably heard of that before,
but it's like this deep level that I've only
slipped into probably a dozen times and I'm
like, "Oh, shit.
There's a deep well here."
Tim Ferriss: That was a little bit of a flex
there.
Kevin Rose: No, no, no, no, no.
Tim Ferriss: Only 200 times or 300 times.
Kevin Rose: No, no, no.
That's not even near what the, it's just a-
Tim Ferriss: Okay, I'm just fucking with you.
Kevin Rose: It's a deep seated meditation.
It's not enlightenment or any crazy thing.
I'm not flexing that hard it.
But it's like, it's a very hard thing to find.
And it turns out that the more you chase it,
the more it flees, which is because you're
trying for something versus just relaxing
into the moment.
But anyway.
Tim Ferriss: It's true for happiness in general,
I would say.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, isn't it?
Isn't it?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: I'll say the one thing that I
really loved about...
By the way, a couple things to mention about
Henry as well, just to give him a little plug.
He is my teacher.
You mentioned the Waking Up app.
I agree with you wholeheartedly.
That was a turning point for me.
I started listening to the Waking Up app.
I paid for it.
Love Sam's content.
Think it's well researched.
It's probably the most, it's the best meditation
app for people that aren't looking to necessarily
just check a box but actually want to go a
little bit deeper because it has the supporting
content that can allow you to go-
Tim Ferriss: The conversations and the essays
are excellent.
And he has, I think Henry on the app also.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, well that's how I discovered
Henry was, Henry was Sam somehow found him
as a Zen teacher.
And Henry has several courses on the Waking
Up app.
So if you're curious about who we're talking
to or talking about, you can go and check
out Henry's content on the Waking Up app and
also enjoy the app as well.
Because it's a great well-made product that
Sam has put together.
Tim Ferriss: And Henry's voice, he has this
mellifluous, delsich tones.
It's fantastic.
He's the kind of guy, if he read you the,
as Neil Gaiman did once, the Cheesecake Factory
menu, you'd be like, "Oh, I could listen to
this all day."
He's got a great voice.
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Got a great voice.
Kevin Rose: Absolutely.
Anyway, so couple other things on my list
of New Year's resolutions and then Tim, I'd
love to hear your final list as well.
So two boring things, but I think we can all
relate.
One, organizing my photos on the photos app
inside of photos, like Jesus, it's a mess.
I got to go do that.
I want to do that this year at some point.
Tim Ferriss: Wait.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait, wait.
How are you going to do that?
Because I look at my photos and I don't even
take that many photos, right?
The youngsters out there take, whatever it
is, 20 selfies a day.
Kevin Rose: You send me a lot of bad stuff.
Tim Ferriss: Those are usually the most-
Kevin Rose: Those two dudes awful with the
one dude in the center.
Tim Ferriss: Wait, what?
No, those weren't dudes.
Kevin Rose: With the whipped cream.
Tim Ferriss: Those were not dudes.
Kevin Rose: Oh, those aren't dudes?
Tim Ferriss: You got to watch again.
No, they're not dudes.
Anyway, so those are the most hideous things
that my friends send me in these various group
texts.
And by the way, side note, anyone out there
who as their personal theater chooses mock
outrage, like, oh my God, I can't believe,
da da da da.
Every one of you, if you had your group text
shared, you'd go down in flames like the rest
of the world.
So please.
Kevin Rose: Oh my God.
Dude, if I had my friend's group text shared,
you and I would both, it would be game over.
Tim Ferriss: Everyone.
No, but here's what would happen is the entire
world would be canceled.
And if you wouldn't be canceled, I'm like,
I'm so sorry your life is so boring and your
friends have no sense of humor.
Kevin Rose: That's the whole thing is, one
of the things I love about my friends is that
we can all give each other shit, we take it
and we also share things that are just so
ridiculous they make us laugh, but we're having
fun with life.
We're just, it's humor.
And we realize that.
But you know if that thread got on the internet,
people would be like, "Oh my God, they made
a joke about this."
And it's like it's, I'm not making any jokes
that I wouldn't, like I have no problem with...
My jokes wouldn't be considered to be, like
they'd be considered to be crude but not-
Tim Ferriss: Oh no.
The apologies start already.
Kevin Rose: No, I'm trying to classify them.
They're not jokes that people would be like,
"Oh, he's a woman hater or a racist or something
like that."
Those aren't the jokes.
They're more just a little bit crude and a
little bit rough around the edges.
But it's fun.
Tim Ferriss: Just a little crude.
Just a little crude.
Kevin Rose: Dude, your shit is, I couldn't
even show Daria some of the stuff you sent
me.
I showed-
Tim Ferriss: Of course you can.
Of course you can.
Kevin Rose: I showed her the little thing
with the two people bumping and she was like,
"Jesus."
Tim Ferriss: Oh no, that was terrible.
That was one-
Kevin Rose: That was one the worst one's you've
ever sent me.
Tim Ferriss: Oh yeah.
It was so bad.
Well, I mean, kind of relates to my NFT project
in a way, but it's like you know there's something
horrible and special when you're in a group
thread and I'm not a woman.
I don't want to speak for women.
Men I think just in general are much cruder,
much rougher.
I could be wrong.
Please prove me wrong.
But there's some just terrible shit that floats
around.
And again, it's not anything that would be
illegal, but it's just in its own way jaw
dropping.
Kevin Rose: Here comes the backpedal.
Tim Ferriss: No, no, I'm not backpedaling.
I'm not backpedaling.
Now that you've got me started on this whole
apologizing to the woke supremacist thing,
now I've been drafted into this thankless
task.
But the point I was going to make is, I don't
know if you've had this experience, but you're
in a group thread with a bunch of guys and
it's just constant nonsense.
It's just nonsense.
Kevin Rose: Oh, of course.
Tim Ferriss: Dick jokes-
Kevin Rose: That's all it is.
Tim Ferriss: Nonsense, nonsense, nonsense.
And then one person will throw something in
and everyone's like, "Ooh God, Jesus God,
it's terrible."
Kevin Rose: Totally.
And then you immediately send it to five of
your friends.
Tim Ferriss: And I immediately send it to
you.
When I get one of those gems, I immediately
send it to you.
Kevin Rose: Well, me and Sacca.
You do have-
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kevin Rose: Sometimes Sacca's on there too.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, we do have some good ones.
We do have some good ones.
How how the hell did we get on this?
Kevin Rose: Okay, so we were talking, okay,
I was talking about organizing my photos.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, photos.
So wait, how would you even do that though?
Because it seems like such an overwhelming
task.
Kevin Rose: It is.
It's not even probably worth talking about.
I would just fire up the photos app, and I'm
going to go back in time and start going to
town and just deleting a bunch of crap.
Tim Ferriss: Definitely not going to do that.
Okay, continue.
Kevin Rose: So here's a more important one
though.
This actually is something that I, two things.
Well, we don't have to talk about the one,
but the one thing that I do want to do is
I'm really trying to figure out-
Tim Ferriss: Wait, wait, what was the one
you don't want to talk about?
Kevin Rose: Well, no, I've started coding
again-
Tim Ferriss: Butt plugs tell me.
Kevin Rose: No, no.
Not the plugs that you love.
By the way, no, we're not going to get in
that.
So this is just going off the rails quickly.
So I am starting to code again.
Tim Ferriss: So when I moved from keto to
tequila, that's when all the trouble starts.
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
That's how you know.
This is going to be a good episode.
I'm actually really proud of us.
Tim Ferriss: It's solid.
Kevin Rose: We finally had another holiday
drinking one, which is great.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
Next time in person.
Kevin Rose: The one thing that I was going
to mention is that just for fun, I am starting
coding again.
I want to do something generative on the NFT
side, and hopefully have something ready for
our conference in May, just for fun.
And then the last thing I would say, and it's
something that's really important to me is,
I want to do this yearly delete of things.
And I have this rule and tell me, Tim, if
you have a better idea-
Tim Ferriss: Physical things.
Kevin Rose: Physical things.
Yeah.
And so what I'm thinking is that if I haven't
used something in six months, or maybe I should
even shorten it to three months, let's call
it clothing, devices, et cetera.
Something that's sitting around in your house.
Just donate it.
Donate it, give it away to Goodwill, let it
find the home it belongs in and reduce your
stuff to like, I'd love to cut in half, to
be honest.
I don't need all the crap.
How do you feel about that?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
I have some policies for myself that have
been very helpful I think.
And sometimes I over-correct and I'll explain
why over-correcting makes sense, at least
for me.
The first is, and I'm sure you get this, but
I think I get it to a much greater degree.
Maybe when you were at the helm of Digg, this
was an issue.
I get sent so much shit.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: It is unbelievable.
I just get mountains of stuff sent.
Kevin Rose: We're in the same boat, dude.
Yeah, that's part of why I was thinking about
it.
It's like you get a lot of books, you get
a lot of swag-
Tim Ferriss: Stuff.
Kevin Rose: You get a lot of things.
Yeah, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: You get a lot of stuff.
And so one of my rules, and I don't follow
it perfectly, but some rules followed imperfectly
still add a lot of benefit.
And in my case, if I'm going to keep something
new, I try to get rid of something.
So if I'm going to accept one thing in, one
thing's going to go.
If somebody sends me, maybe it's a really
comfortable shirt that has some clever thing
on it and there's some really minimal branding
for their company and it's a friend's thing
and I'm like, "Okay, this is a comfortable
shirt.
Maybe I'll keep this."
I will try to find a shirt that I get rid
of because I have simply too much stuff.
I will also go through periods of purging.
And I try to do it leading into the winter.
Because, frankly, if you're out there and
you have warm clothing, meaning clothing for
cold weather.
If you have layers or thicker clothing or
longsleeve shirts that you are not using and
you will not use this winter, holy shit, there
are people who need that.
There are people who are homeless, there are
people who are without means to buy clothing
for themselves or their children.
Donate that stuff.
And here's what I would say.
If you're on the fence, give it away.
And I don't want to do too much of the Marie
Kondo stuff, but it's like, if it doesn't
spark joy, here's what I would say.
This is another-
Kevin Rose: I love your accents by the way.
They're so good every time you do one.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you.
Yeah, if anybody didn't know, it's not Marie
Kondo, even though it's very convenient for
the English-speaking market.
It's Maria, Maria, Maria Kondo.
Kevin Rose: Maria Kondo.
Tim Ferriss: And yeah, she has the most perfect
skin of all time, by the way.
People can find a photograph of me with her.
I interviewed her in Japan.
Kevin Rose: Was it figured out what her secret
is?
Tim Ferriss: Genetics maybe.
It's like an AI created the perfect human
porcelain doll, it's unbelievable.
I don't know what it is.
Kevin Rose: Are you attracted to her?
Tim Ferriss: She's cute.
Oh, absolutely.
She's also married and has a family and that's
not something I'm going for.
But she's a good looking woman.
Jesus Christ.
All right.
Anyway, no, but let me come back to this process.
Kevin Rose: And I have a question for you,
but go ahead.
About buying stuff.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, for sure.
So what I try to do when I look in, whether
it's my closet or at things I own, is ask
on a scale of say one to 10, how much joy
am I getting out of this?
Or how much use am I getting out of this?
And then the follow-up question is, no matter
what the answer is, if it's a 10, I keep it.
If it's a nine, I'd probably keep it.
If it's an eight, I'd probably still keep
it.
But if it's less than that, could I give this
to someone?
Could I donate this to someone who would absolutely
get an eight, nine, or 10 use or joy out of
this?
If so, get rid of it.
And if you have some means, and that doesn't
mean millions of dollars, but getting rid
of a T-shirt or two is probably not going
to break the bank for a lot of people.
In which case, when in doubt, donate it.
Give it to someone who can't afford to buy
the shirt.
And if you decide later, you know what?
Oh, I really liked that T-shirt.
I really like that V-neck.
I really liked that fill in the blank.
You can buy it again.
And I rarely end up doing that, but every
once in a while I'll do a full purge where
I'll just take garbage bags and garbage bags
of stuff and donate it to Goodwill or somewhere
else.
And then I'll realize, "Ah, okay, I kind of
got overzealous.
I got rid of that one thing that I wore all
the time."
And then I'll just buy it again on Amazon.
It's there two days later.
It's fine.
Kevin Rose: Let me ask you, I have a very
personal question and something that I haven't
shared before that I'd like to ask you about
buying things and-
Tim Ferriss: Oh boy.
Wow.
Kevin Rose: No, I just think that this is
something that nobody talks about.
And I always like to, you're so good at finding
stuff that you can pick up and you're a very
open person, which I've always appreciated
about your podcast and just how you are transparent
about feelings and emotions and a lot of things
that I think a lot of men could use to look
up to in terms of-
Tim Ferriss: Oh God, is this question going
to be a fucking hydrogen bomb?
Kevin Rose: This is a tough one.
No, no, no.
So here's a problem that I've had, just being
completely honest.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: There was, back when I was in
my 20s and early 30s, Digg was doing quite
well, which was my startup for those of you
who don't know, it was early social news website
that was, it was killing it.
We had 38 million people a month that were
visiting on the site.
Tim Ferriss: Huge.
Kevin Rose: Back then, it was one of the top
sites on the internet.
It was crazy.
It started to go sideways and it started to
go down and we were losing to Reddit.
Reddit was starting to kick our ass in some
certain ways and we had dominated them for
many years.
And then all of a sudden that was not the
case and we were kind of reeling a little
bit.
I had sold a tiny bit of my stock, enough
to be able to afford an apartment and actually
buy and put a down payment on an apartment
and that's how I got my Paige Street place
in SF.
And I remember thinking to myself, I need
to buy myself something to like, it was a
search to feel better.
And so I went out and I actually bought, and
this is going to sound super douchey, but
I'm okay to say this today.
Actually I bought a Porsche.
I bought a Porsche 911 back in the day.
And looking back on that, I realized I was
just in a really difficult, sad state.
It was hard for me to watch this baby of mine
and I didn't know how to course correct it.
I was just so immature in a bunch of different
ways.
But I was buying for the sake of trying to
fill a gap.
Don't get me wrong, I still think vintage
Porsches and old Porsches and Porsches in
general, they're just beautiful cars.
I think they're great.
I don't have a 911 today, but I will say that
I'd noticed the same thing.
Tim Ferriss: Kevin is not anti-Porsche in
his group text messaging.
Kevin Rose: I'm not anti-Porsche.
Please don't cancel me, Porsche.
I would love to be sponsored if you want to
sponsor me.
I'm happy to drive a 911.
So that said, here's the crazy thing.
I went and ran Hokinkee, the luxury watch
brand company, I was CEO there for a few years
and loved my experience there because we were
covering mechanical, like a dying art.
It was mechanical timepieces.
And it was very beautiful in its purest form.
In its purest form, you talk to an artisan
that is a single independent watchmaker that
takes a year and a half to build something
from scratch and sells 10 a year.
That's beautiful.
Those days are going away.
In its douchey form, you're talking to Lambo
drivers that just want to have a flex that
they can hold the watch on their wrist that
says I have $5 million on my wrist.
That's a real thing.
And so I met with a lot, as CEO of this company,
it still is the largest watch brand editorial
site in the world.
And you would meet all these collectors and
they would come up to you and they come in
all different shapes and sizes.
And it was clear to me that some of these
dudes, bless them, they were trying to fill
that same thing that I was trying to fill,
where you go out and you spend money on something
to make yourself feel in a group, to feel
connection.
Because you'd come out and you'd say, "These
are other collectors like me."
And it's tough.
And I'm not anti-watch, I'm wearing an Apple
Watch today, but I still have a few time pieces
that are really meaningful to me, including
one that my dad left me when he passed away.
And I still love that whole thing.
But how do you approach this as somebody,
have you ever spent your money on things?
And then how do you approach it with...
Have you ever done that?
And then also, how do you approach that with
significant others?
I've had this conversation with my wife about,
"Hey, we don't have to wear the flashy stuff.
It's okay to wear..."
I told her the other night, one of my favorite
times to hang out with you is when it's jeans
and T-shirts version of you at a bar.
I love that.
Like having a beer.
Tim Ferriss: Totally.
Kevin Rose: We don't have to be fancy LA.
I don't want that.
Where do you stand on all this stuff?
Tim Ferriss: So I think, and you've probably
observed this in me.
Kevin Rose: You're so good at this.
This is why I'm trying to pick your brain.
You don't have to do any flashy shit.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I'm good, I'm good.
But there is a downside.
There is a trade-off and I have not figured
out how to contend with this.
And I'll actually mention also a book that
has come up several times in the last week
from multiple people I respect and remember
Rick Rubin, the music producer, said to me,
when that happens to him, he feels like it's
a signal from the universe that he needs to
take a look at something.
And so I kind of feel like that right now
with this book, which I'll come to in a second.
I have had very few instances of buying expensive
things for myself.
And you've seen this.
Kevin Rose: I know.
Tim Ferriss: I don't think I'm stingy in all
things.
For instance, I will go to, if I think the
experience is going to leave an indelible
mark in my mind, I will go to a place like
Alinea in Chicago and have a meal.
And I did that and I'm really glad I did.
And it's very expensive.
I would consider it very expensive.
It's like 1,500, 2,000 bucks for a meal.
And that on some level would make the 15-year-old
version of me go into a seizure.
I did not grow up with a lot of money and
grew up in a household where scarcity of money
was an issue.
Kevin Rose: Oh my God.
My dad would yell at my mom for spending too
much money and stuff because we would literally
bounce checks.
I remember that being a conversation, like
the account is overdrawn.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
It was a source of stress.
And so I decided pretty early on as a kid,
okay, I do not want this type of stress in
my life.
That means I need to figure out how to make
money.
And that in a way was the spark behind my
entrepreneurial experiments.
Kevin Rose: That's a great point.
Tim Ferriss: This type of stress that I have
been immersed in and exposed to, and I don't
think it traumatized me.
I wouldn't put it that way.
I wouldn't want to remove the power of that
word trauma by applying it to something like
this.
And I think it kind of disgusted me how overused
the word trauma is.
That's a separate thing.
But it affected me.
It definitely imprinted something on me.
And as a result, I have spent relatively little
money celebrating anything.
The fact that I spent, like these Japanese
saddles, I bought them at auction from, I
can't remember, it was Christie's or Sotheby's,
and I think it was $5,000 a piece.
And to allow myself to do that, the hurdle
was, not only do I have to finish and publish
a book that is 500 plus pages, I think it
was maybe 700 pages, which was cut down from
probably 1,500 pages.
Kevin Rose: Was this in your head or something
you wrote down?
Like this was a hurdle that you had to-
Tim Ferriss: It was in my head.
But I said, if I publish this book and it
is number one New York Times, I will allow
myself, as a reward, to buy these saddles
that cost $5,000 each.
And if I don't, I'm not allowed to do this.
So on some level I respect that and it's very
strict, high standards.
And on some level all of those things are
good.
But what I will say is when I meet or spend
time with friends of mine who have achieved
some degree of success, and it's not always
millions of dollars.
They've just figured out a job and a skill
where they've developed a career and they're
stable and they fix a lot of problems for
themselves and they add a lot of joy for themselves
and their families by spending money.
The dark side of what I'm describing is that
I don't think I've developed that very well.
And so I have more money than I know what
to do with.
And I think I put it, I don't want to sound
like a prick.
That doesn't mean that I'm just doing backstroke
through a pool full of gold coins like Scrooge
McDuck.
That's not what I'm saying.
I think I am a very, very, hopefully this
doesn't sound pompous.
I think I am a very, very good capital allocator
and steward of money.
I think I use what I have to very high leverage
means and objectives through funding the science
and the journalism fellowship with Michael
Pollan and so on.
But here's what I'll say, Kevin, is there's
a dark side to it in that I don't use money
to fix problems that I should fix.
Kevin Rose: Like what?
Give me an example.
Tim Ferriss: I'll give you an example which
would be, there are little things...
I'll give you a perfect example.
So there is an article, it's not really an
article, it's more an adaptation of John Stuart
Mill's ideas on free speech, which is an illustrated
edition.
It's called All Minus One.
You can find it on Amazon, you can also get
it for free.
I think it's at heterodoxacademy.org/mill.
And this came about through a conversation
with Jonathan Haidt, who's fascinating thinker
and professor and researcher who wrote The
Coddling of the American Mind and many other
books.
So this is, let's see, on Kindle, it's I think
78 pages.
And I agonized over when I was going to find
time to print this and put it together in
a hard copy so that I could mark it up.
Because I didn't want to wait for the paper
back.
This is stupid.
I have employees.
I could send this to someone and just be like,
"Hey, figure this out.
Whatever makes it readable, go."
It would've taken 30 seconds.
But there's part of me, for whatever reason,
that gets stuck on doing it myself and doesn't
even consider that.
It doesn't enter my head as an option.
And there are many other examples of this.
I've been to friends' houses where they love,
let's not name names, but well, because you'll
probably get it.
But I have a friend who really loves Topo
Chico and you go to his house and he always
has the refrigerator drawer full of Topo Chico.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
I love that.
Tim Ferriss: It's never empty.
He never runs out.
Kevin Rose: It's extra sparkly.
It's good.
Tim Ferriss: It is.
Yeah, it'll definitely take all the enamel
off your teeth.
It's delicious.
And even though all the hipster Austinites
have boycotted it, because it's owned by the
evil empire of Coca-Cola now so they're drinking
Richard's Rainwater and others, which are
fine.
Fine, fine, fine sparkling water.
But I just find the outrage pretty hilarious.
But the point is, he has a team.
He pays people to help him and his family
with their lives in various ways so that he
can focus on things he's really good at, which
does not include figuring out at the last
minute, "Oh shit, I'm out of Topo Chico, how
am I going to make it in time to the grocery
store to buy this and chew up 45 minutes of
my time?"
I don't have many of those systems in place,
and it's not because I am consciously deciding
I need to save money.
It's like the option doesn't even appear on
my mental UI to choose.
So this is something I'm trying to figure
out, which leads to the book, which has been
recommended a number of times now, which is
called Die With Zero.
I've not read it.
Kevin Rose: I've heard about this, actually.
Tim Ferriss: So full disclosure now.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, Chris Hutchens sent this
to me.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, no shit.
Okay.
So Bill Perkins is the author, and I should
know better than to recommend something before
I've read it.
So I just want to make it super clear, I have
not read this.
But the book is Die With Zero: Getting All
You Can From Your Money and Your Life.
And it's written by Bill Perkins, who's a
famous energy trader/investor and The Wall
Street Journal bestseller.
I'll just read a little bit of the description,
which is very seductive to me because it's
written by someone who has also been an operator.
If this book were written by just someone
who's waxing poetic without any real bonafides,
bonafides, I would be skeptical.
But this is someone who's actually been a
real operator in the trenches.
So the description is a common sense guide
to living rich instead of dying rich.
Imagine if by the time you died you did everything
you were told to.
You worked hard, saved your money, and looked
forward to financial freedom when you retired.
The only thing you wasted along the way was...
Your life.
Die With Zero presents a startling new and
provocative philosophy as well as practical
guide on how to get the most out of your money
and the most out of your life.
It's intended for those who place lifelong
memorable experiences far ahead of simply
making and accumulating money for ones so-called
golden years.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And it goes on.
This is interesting to me and I'm hoping that
it provides me with some counter programming
that will maybe help me to do more.
And I have, I will say, been finding some
outlets where I don't have hangups, and one
is spending money on art or supporting artists.
So I will be doing, moving forward quite a
few experiments with artists and artwork.
I did one that is actually running right now
as we record.
It's going to end in a few hours.
But it's a competition for AI generated or
enhanced artwork.
Kevin Rose: Cockpunch-related or no?
Tim Ferriss: Cockpunch related.
Kevin Rose: Are you serious?
Tim Ferriss: So they have to work...
Yeah, yeah.
CockPunch related.
And the stuff that has come out is beyond
belief.
It is hard to wrap my head around and I say
this as someone who has quite a bit of art
background and worked as an illustrator, paid
a lot of bills as an illustrator for magazines
and books in college.
It is hard to wrap my head around what this
technology will do for creative expression.
And it's controversial.
Kevin Rose: Oh, big time.
Tim Ferriss: I have seen blowback because
AI, whether it's ChatGPT for text or other
tools requires training data.
So where do you get that training data?
If it's graphical expression, if it's what
we would consider visual art, they might be
pulling from, say, artists on Art Station.
Kevin Rose: Right.
But it's blending it so well together that
you could never pick out individually which
artist is pulling from.
Tim Ferriss: Sometimes, unless in your prompt
you say, instead of in the style of Van Gogh,
which most people would consider fair game.
If it's in the style of fill in the blank
contemporary artists who makes their living
selling prints in part or doing commissioned
artwork, is that net positive or a net negative
for them?
I don't know.
Kevin Rose: You now who you should talk to,
you know who's fun to chat with this is, I
was talking to Mike Shinoda about this, our
mutual friend from Lincoln Park, and he was
talking about how there's this list that you
can sign up for that apparently will exclude
you from the training data if you really want
out of it.
Tim Ferriss: It's like the do not call list.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
He was saying that because in music you could
imagine this is going to be a big deal.
You're going to say, hey-
Tim Ferriss: I'm already seeing Stable Diffusion
applied to music in ways that make your head
spin.
And it's so early.
It's not even the first inning.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
I was asking him about like, "Hey, what do
you think of AI when it says, Hey, play me
a song like it was written by Mike Shinoda."
And what does that sound like?
And it's a big topic to go into.
Tim Ferriss: How does he feel?
How does he feel?
Kevin Rose: I don't want to speak for him,
but at that time, I got the sense, and I'm
just paraphrasing here, I'm actually not even
going to paraphrase.
I'm going to say that I got the sense that
it's early days and if anything I know about
Mike is definitely he embraces the future.
There's no doubt about it.
He's all Web3, he's doing NFT drops, he's
doing [inaudible 01:33:30] stuff with music.
He's awesome on that front.
But at the same time, I can imagine if you're
an artist in his position, which is just the
top tier, top 1% of all musical artists out
there, you also want to protect who you are
as an individual in your IP.
Now the sense I got from him is figuring out
how this is going to weave and what you're
going to have to do in the future.
So, he'd be a fun one to have on and eventually
talk about this stuff.
Tim Ferriss: I should have him back on.
I had him on the podcast like 100 years ago.
Kevin Rose: Oh, he's such a good dude.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, great guy.
On the AI front, I will say, I have artists
in my family.
I see how hard it is.
I've been there myself.
I should point out also that I am not necessarily
immune to the influence of these technologies,
in the sense that I have seen blog posts generated
using predominantly AI with very few prompts
and things are going to change for writers.
Kevin Rose: Oh my God, it's so scary.
Tim Ferriss: In a big way.
That will particularly apply to non-fiction
writers, and I am principally a non-fiction
writer.
Kevin Rose: The fiction writers, dude, a lot
of these tools are being done around fiction.
Tim Ferriss: Fiction.
Fiction is going to be harder.
I think fiction will be a lot harder to thread,
but both will be affected.
So there are many questions that this prompts,
pun intended.
One is, what are the factors that will drive,
say reading, in my case?
How much of it will be being certain that
you are reading something generated by a human
before you're willing to commit to having
an emotional response, even if the output
is identical?
Will there be some authenticity of human production
that becomes important?
I could see that becoming important.
Kevin Rose: Interesting.
Tim Ferriss: Do you really want to cry watching
a movie that was 100% produced by robots?
Maybe not.
Maybe that is a hard line that people draw
where they're like, I don't actually want
to have my emotions manipulated by machines.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, but you already do today
with the graphics, right?
Those are created by machines.
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
Oh yeah.
So no, it's a question of degree.
Kevin Rose: Let me ask you question-
Tim Ferriss: We're already being affected.
Kevin Rose: What you're saying, Tim, is, let's
just jump forward 20 years from now, you're
saying there is a world where you could imagine
a novel that would have some type of designation
on it digitally that would say this was human
written, just to ensure-
Tim Ferriss: Oh, absolutely.
Kevin Rose: That's so crazy.
That's awesome.
Tim Ferriss: Absolutely.
Imagine you have these time pieces that are
one of a kind, produced by the labor of one
or a handful of people over a year and a half.
The origin and the story matter.
You could produce something maybe even superior
with advanced robotics and software and so
on.
But you want the physical and psychic imprint.
Kevin Rose: It's the human connection.
Yeah, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
So I think absolutely.
Just you have a stamp for organic or humane
certified or free trade, it'd be like human-generated
stamp.
I would be surprised if that's not a thing.
Kevin Rose: You should go in and file your
trademarks and patents.
Tim Ferriss: So, that'll be a thing.
Let me add a few more though.
So another one will be, actually this is more
philosophical, so I thought about the counter-arguments
and the blowback related to AI before I launched
this competition.
I understood the counter-arguments, and I
don't disagree with them.
This is going to affect the competitive landscape
for artists, period.
Full stop.
Kevin Rose: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: Especially for things like logo
design, things of this type.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Of course, Fiverr is fucked.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Like website layout and so on.
The way I'm looking at it is if I, Tim, wanted
to help as many artists as possible, what
would my chess move be?
Where I landed was we are going from the horse
and the horse drawn carriage to the car.
That transition is happening whether we want
it to or not.
If we own a bunch of horses, if we own a bunch
of carriages, if we own the equivalent of
a taxi service back in the day, that's fine.
But the technology is going to change.
So if you want to be in a competitive position,
if you want to have advantages, you need to
be on the front end of learning about these
technologies.
Which is part of the reason why I wanted to
do this competition, to say, hey guys, you
can make this work for you in a lot of ways,
but you got to be on the early end.
You just have to.
Kevin Rose: There's a couple things that I
think are important to point out here in that,
to me, this just represents another leap forward
in technology.
I would say the closest parallel I have to
this is probably the graphical user interface
that was done by the Mac and-
Tim Ferriss: Netscape for web browser.
Kevin Rose: Well, imagine you were an artist
back in the day.
To draw a circle meant you had to sit down
and try and draw a circle.
Now in Photoshop-
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
You needed a compass.
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
Then now in Photoshop you can literally say-
Tim Ferriss: God, I'm so fucking old.
Kevin Rose: I love you pulled the compass
reference, that's great.
But now you can literally-
Tim Ferriss: Pencil is too short.
I'm getting a wobbly circle.
Let me sharpen that thing.
Kevin Rose: Right.
So those days are gone and that's okay.
I'm sure there were some artists that were
like, fuck Photoshop for making that perfect
circle.
I used to have to hand draw those.
That's what we're going through today with
this next jump.
It's going to be tough for a few years.
It's going to feel weird, it's going to feel
not right.
Then finally we'll understand what the tool
actually is.
Tim Ferriss: Also, I'll just say, if you're
early, you can learn how to use the tools,
rather than be abused by the adoption of the
tools.
It's super important.
If you learn early, holy shit, you have tremendous
advantage.
So learn early, start experimenting now.
I'll give you another prediction.
I was thinking about this.
Imagine, if you will, I feel like Dan Carlin
with Hardcore History, imagine if you will,
General Subutai.
No, let me come back.
So imagine that you have a book, you have
a nonfiction book.
It's a biography of a contemporary figure.
Teddy Roosevelt, whatever.
I think it's Theodore Rex, I think is this
multi-volume biography that I've been meaning
to read forever.
I just keep putting it off because it's so
long.
I've heard it's amazing, but I haven't been
willing to commit.
It's just too long.
I think there will be a time, probably in
the next year, wouldn't surprise me.
Within the next year, I would imagine for
books that are well reviewed, have a lot of
coverage and are contemporary, meaning within
the last 100 years, I will be able to say
something along the lines of, with a prompt
interface to stable diffusion or any number
of other tools.
I think a lot of these tools will get combined
into user interfaces where the underlying
mechanics are invisible.
Kevin Rose: Oh my god.
Dude, wait, pause for one second.
Can I slip something in real quick?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, of course.
Kevin Rose: There is a service you have to
try.
I don't know if you ever remember our buddy
Addison Kowalski.
He created prompthunt.com.
It's taking exactly what you said where right
now it's 50 words to create this prompt, this
perfect AI.
Tim Ferriss: That's cool.
Kevin Rose: It's making themes around it and
it's really cool.
It's exactly what you're talking about.
Tim Ferriss: This'll do well.
If it's executed well, prompthunt.com will
do well because the magic is in the prompt.
It's like being a magician with the spell.
Kevin Rose: That's what they realized.
Tim Ferriss: You have to get the incantation
right.
If you don't, zero, you come up or you get
some fucking mangled monstrosity.
Side note really quickly, rhinoskinsolutions.com
is what I was referring to earlier.
The dry spray and the Mikey's tip juice, sounds
porno, is what I have.
So, there you go.
Kevin Rose: What are you talking about?
You talking about the hand stuff?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, the antiperspirant for
the hands.
Kevin Rose: That was a big callback.
Tim Ferriss: It was a big callback.
Kevin Rose: Okay, so let me do one more quick
callback.
Side note, this is the last one, I promise.
For all those that we talked about, Tim, you
mentioned the book Die With Zero, our friend
Chris Hutchins.
The reason I said that he had mentioned it
to me.
He actually did a podcast with him.
So, I know you love Chris.
He has a podcast called All the Hacks.
So, All the Hacks, Die With Zero is the one
to check out.
Anyway, but I thought you'd find it interesting.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, Chris is very diligent.
I will say-
Kevin Rose: He is like a mini you.
Honestly.
Tim Ferriss: I want to give him more credit.
The first Chris Hutchins.
I thought I was OCD about prep.
He's given me a run for my money.
He really does a lot of preparation and is
meticulous in how he approaches the details
of these things.
So, I'll check out that podcast and we'll
link to it in the show notes.
AI prediction, big book.
Three volumes, biography.
Fuck, I'm never going to listen to that or
I'm never going to read that.
I could put in a prompt, which is something
like create a Ken Burns-like documentary that
allows me to cover the most important parts
of fill in the blank book or book series with
archival photographs or footage with a voice
overlay that provides narration, which is
pulling from the highlights of that book,
using sources like quotes from Goodreads.
Kevin Rose: Ah, this is going to fuck you,
by the way.
Tim Ferriss: It's totally going to fuck me.
I am absolutely going to be simultaneously
the beneficiary and the Cock Punch recipient
of artificial intelligence.
100%.
It's going to rock the boat in such a significant
way.
But what I'm committed to doing is being a
student of the craft because it is the Model
T and the car coming after horse drawn carriages.
This is inevitable.
It is not reversible.
Sadly, there's no lobby I can think of.
Kevin Rose: No, it's open source.
Tim Ferriss: It's out of the bottle.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, it's out of the bottle.
Tim Ferriss: So, there's that.
Should we talk about cockacidal maniac?
Kevin Rose: Yeah, let's talk about your Cock
Punch.
Tim Ferriss: Let's have anybody name that
movie reference cockacidal maniac.
Do you get that reference?
Kevin Rose: No, I don't.
You're older than I am.
Tim Ferriss: It's a bar.
Oh gee, I'm older than you are.
Give a break.
Look at those white whiskers you got over
there, Mr. Sea Otter.
Kevin Rose: Oh, fuck you.
At least I have hair biatch.
I got hair underneath here.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's true.
You do have a nice Los Angeles slick going
with that black hair.
What the fuck was I just talking about?
Oh yeah, cockacidal maniac.
Very important film reference.
This is a reference, it takes place in a bar
scene in the Winchester in Shaun of the Dead.
S-H-A-U-N.
Kevin Rose: Oh, I know Shaun of the Dead.
Haven't watched that in forever.
Tim Ferriss: One of the greatest of all time.
I watched it several hundred times as background
when I was writing The 4-Hour Workweek.
Kevin Rose: That's awesome.
Tim Ferriss: Little known fact.
Kevin Rose: Do have gray hairs yet or no?
Tim Ferriss: Oh my god, I'm covered in gray
hairs, man.
Yeah, I was fortunate/unfortunate to lose
my hair before my hair went gray on my head.
But chest hair, beard hair, salt and pepper
mania.
Absolutely.
Kevin Rose: Do you get the grays?
Tim Ferriss: The grays down under?
Kevin Rose: I've had a couple down there.
Tim Ferriss: Of course, I do.
How would you have anybody who's like, yeah,
I have gray in my beard and gray in my chest,
but my pubes are the mane of black stallion.
Give me a fucking break, that's bullshit.
Kevin Rose: I swear.
I only have had two and it's depressing.
It's depressing because you trim them real
quick because you going to get them out of
there.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I gave up on that.
Kevin Rose: Did you?
You're just full gray.
You're Santa down there.
Santa's little beard.
Tim Ferriss: I'm like Adam Gazzaley's beard
on my balls.
You're welcome Adam.
Kevin Rose: Leave that in.
Oh my God.
Tim Ferriss: One of the greatest neuroscientists
of the modern age.
Kevin Rose: You basically just called him
a ball sack.
I love that.
All right, so Cock Punch, how's NFT land been
for you?
Tim Ferriss: Well, let me ask you this first.
I'm happy to talk about all of it.
I will say, just to preface the whole thing,
I am still having so much fun.
There was a Death Valley of anger and the
trough of sorrow for sure.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
The taint of sorrow.
It's like you have to travel through.
Tim Ferriss: The taint of sorrow was sorrowful.
So I'm not going to downplay that, we can
talk about it.
But what did you expect was going to happen?
Let me start there because you've been through
this rodeo multiple times now.
Kevin Rose: Honestly, Tim, I knew you were
fucked.
I would've said something if I thought it
was career ending for you.
I didn't think that.
What I thought was that I told Darya this
actually, my wife this.
I said, "I'm glad that Tim has enough money
to not give a fuck, because he's having fun."
All you can ask for anyone, I think about
this with my kids a lot at the end of the
day, because Darya is an academic and she
got her PhD in neuroscience and I clearly
am not.
I'm a college dropout.
At the end of the day, what I want for my
children is them to find their life's work
and their fun in life.
Their joy.
Tim Ferriss: Did you see them for to find?
Kevin Rose: What?
Did I fuck that up?
Tim Ferriss: You say them for to find?
Kevin Rose: For them to find.
Tim Ferriss: That was an amazing sentence.
Tim Ferriss: For them to find.
Oh, okay.
I think you threw an extra word or two.
Kevin Rose: Go ahead.
I probably did.
I'm sure.
I'm deep into this bottle of fantastic wine,
which I will say is the mascot.
So all jokes aside, I love when I see Tim
having a good time because Tim, I've known
you for a long time man.
I know that you're a very interesting cat
in that you're like both insanely playful
but insanely serious at the same time.
You have these two sides of your life that
just sometimes are at odds with each other.
Anytime I can see playful Tim come out, I'm
happy.
I'm a happy person because I love to see you
If this is that for you, it makes me happy.
So, that's great.
Tim Ferriss: Well, what's also a timing hilarity
in all of this is that as I'm about to go
into this huge experiment that I've been working
on forever, and Kevin's my Sherpa.
Kevin Rose: Oh, Jesus.
Put Brenden in there too.
Tim Ferriss: Well no.
Okay, I'm going to give Brendan credit where
credit is due.
But you got me, along with Naval and other
people, interested in Web3.
Actually rewind the clock, you led me to my
first crypto purchases in late 2012, early
2013, somewhere in that range.
You have introduced me to a lot of very important
technological innovations.
You also walked me through, as my meta mass
tech support, my first NFT purchase.
Kevin Rose: I believe I have a shirt that
says that, by the way.
Meta mass tech support.
Tim Ferriss: Meta mass tech support.
VIP white glove tech support.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Then I'm getting ready.
The launch is coming.
Holy shit, I'm nervous.
People on your team are helping me.
Then Kevin's like, "I'm going on a silent
meditation retreat for seven days."
I'm like, what?
So, Kevin disappears, but let me catch you
up.
So Premint, Brenden Mulligan, I have to give
him a lot of credit.
We've both known him for a long time.
Kevin Rose: Good human.
Tim Ferriss: He's a great human.
Yes.
He gives a shit.
He cares about quality.
He is very thoughtful.
I want to give his team credit too, he and
his team executed Lawlessly.
They were so detail oriented, which of course
I appreciate.
Kevin Rose: Don't forget about my team.
So we did smart [inaudible 01:52:11] for you.
Tim Ferriss: No, your team was amazing.
Hold on.
You mentioned Brendan, so I'm mentioning Brendan
first.
So Brendan executed so well, and his team,
prototyping the mint pages as a potential
offering through Premint.
Incredible.
So I just want to give a thanks there.
I'll also give a thanks, of course, to your
entire team, the divergence super squad that
was absorbed, was eaten.
Brought onto the island of proof by KK Ro
Ro.
Kev Kev Rose Rose.
Kevin Rose: KK Ro Ro.
Is that a new one?
Tim Ferriss: That's a new one.
You sounded like the South Park guys doing
some of their voiceovers.
Anyway, some people will get that.
The diversions team, also world class.
Good job by the way.
Kevin Rose: I'm just glad you had a great
mint man.
Everything went fine.
You sold out.
Tim Ferriss: Everything went great.
It sold out.
We, I think, managed it very well.
People get pissed no matter what.
But I think we managed it as well and planned
it as well as we possibly could have.
You know how much I agonized over this, I
held on to multiple variables as undefined
until the 11th hour because I really wanted
to try to satisfy as many people as possible.
With that, it is not possible to make everyone
happy, especially in Web3, especially in NFTs.
But the mint went off without a hitch, and
then the reveal drops a few days later.
Oh, let me back up and just say thank you
to everyone who participated in the primary
sale because it raised $1.8 or so million
for the Saisei Foundation.
All of those funds have already been wired
to the Saisei Foundation, that happened within,
I want to say, 48 hours, 72 hours.
Money is already being distributed to projects.
So, this is not a foundation that sits on
funds.
Those funds are going to immediate use.
I'll be sharing more about that.
The uses, for people who don't know, they
can find Saisei Foundation at S-A-I-S-E-I
foundation.org.
Saisei means rebirth in Japanese.
Has funded and continues to fund critical
early stage research related to treating conditions
like treatment resistant depression, complex
PTSD, so-called intractable conditions that
effectively fail with our first line treatments
currently.
A lot of that is psychedelic assisted therapy
related, but not all of it.
I personally, and Saisei Foundation have been
involved, in funding Mr. White Pubes himself,
God he is going to love that.
Dr. Adam Gazzaley and his amazing work at
Neuroscape.
I'm sorry Adam, we had to do it.
Kevin Rose: It's okay Adam.
It's true though.
Tim Ferriss: But he's such a superstar, he
can get away with it, right?
That guy is an absolute top tier world class
scientist who knows how to navigate all of
the complexities.
Therefore, thanks.
Huge sincere thanks to everybody who participated.
It's all going to very, very high leverage,
high impact stuff.
Then the reveal comes.
The reveal comes, the art comes out.
Some people love it, some people hate it.
I still stand by the art.
I stand by it.
One thing that happened that I did not anticipate
at all is a few things, and I will point out
that I'm paying attention to feedback.
I don't pay attention to, "You said [inaudible
01:56:04] man, fuck you."
I don't pay attention to that.
I'll block you if you do that.
But I do pay attention to valid feedback.
There's a lot of valid feedback.
For instance, because this project is not
a PFP project, it's not a profile pic project.
Even though PFP stands for proof for picture,
I think, or picture for proof.
Kevin Rose: No, profile photo project.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: No, it does not.
It stands for picture for proof.
Look it up.
Ended up being co-opted into profile pic,
there's no F in profile pic project.
Kevin Rose: Jesus, of course you would know
the technical shit.
It just means show me your face on the fucking
Twitter.
Tim Ferriss: Well, that's what it means now.
I just wanted to throw a monkey wrench in
things for a second because I know you're
deep in the wine.
So I wanted to stumble things.
The point being, because it wasn't a profile
pic, and I tried to explain, this is an ELF,
it's an emergent long fiction project.
To explain that, it didn't fit neatly into
any category that people could absorb in a
millisecond for that reason.
When the art was displayed full body, it was
actually, I think, confusing to some people,
even though I'd explained they would be full
body.
Furthermore, the resolution was ratcheted
really far down to be a unique file type that
allows OpenSea, in this case, the ability
to monitor for counterfeits.
So the function is really important.
The function is super important.
They can flag and remove counterfeits and
invitations and scams by utilizing this unique
file type.
But what it did is it ratcheted down, and
I should give a huge thanks to the OpenSea
team.
They were outstanding and helping with this
project in a million different ways.
So I want to give them full credit where credit
is due.
Also, the fact that this file type, which
is incredibly high utility and important for
the platform, and for projects, because immediately
had dozens of scams, just as Moonbird did.
Kevin Rose: Oh, Jesus.
Tim Ferriss: There are a lot of flyby night
grifters in oh for sure the space.
Anywhere there's anonymity, you're going to
run into this.
But once you add money to the mix, shit gets
crazy very quickly.
So that was a good thing, in the sense that
that file type allowed us to contend with
and prevent, or I shouldn't say prevent, but
minimize confusion in the marketplace.
The side effect of that though is that the
resolution was quite low.
As a result, people were not able to see a
lot of the detail of the artwork, especially
because it was full body.
We addressed that later by providing a token
ID lookup where people could say I own Cock
Punch or the leg legend of Cock Punch number
234.
Let me go to cockpunch.com/PFP, put in my
number, I get a high resolution image.
I also get a PFP camera angle from within
Blender for this character.
Kevin Rose: Oh, cool.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Which has been super fun.
Kevin Rose: Wait, one question there.
So if I put in my number, will that give me
a cropped version of the head so I can use
it as a PFP?
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
It'll give the best cropped version of the
head and also the best camera angle from within
Blender, which is 3D modeling software.
Then what I did, because I had created these
AI blended oil paintings of some of these
characters for each of the houses.
So there were eight primary houses in this
world, much like Game of Thrones.
I created what you might consider even a portrait
painting equivalent of each of these iconic
houses.
I did that by using NightCafe, I think it's
also called Night Studio, which largely used
a stable diffusion, but also DALL-E 2 and
a few others, to blend the original artwork
with Van Gogh's self-portrait.
Kevin Rose: Oh, that's amazing.
How did I not see this?
That's probably when I was on my meditation
retreat.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it was.
Kevin Rose: Where do I see this at?
Tim Ferriss: So if you go to, and we can talk
about Twitter because I know that might be
on the docket, we should talk about it, actually.
If you go to Twitter and then say if you go
to-
Kevin Rose: /cockpunch?
Tim Ferriss: Not /cockpunch.
If you go to, I'm just waiting on my browser
to respond.
Wow.
Is my browser slow or is Twitter really slow
right now?
Might be Twitter.
Or it could be that my account is suspended
for the 12th time.
That's been happening a lot.
Kevin Rose: Elon is-
Tim Ferriss: Let me see here.
Kevin Rose: ... blocking you.
Tim Ferriss: Elon hates cock punches.
Okay, I'm having trouble getting to Twitter
display.
But if you go to twitter.com slouch...
Kevin Rose: Happy New Year.
Tim Ferriss: Happy New Year.
If you go to twitter.com slouch.
Kevin Rose: Slouch.
We need t-shirts for just for the random show
to say slouch.
Tim Ferriss: hashtag slouch.
Househallux, Like H-A-L-L-U-X.
Maybe it'll pop up for you
Kevin Rose: Okay.
I went to /H-A-L-L-U-X on Twitter.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Twitter.com/househallux.
So house H-A-L-L-U-X.
Kevin Rose: Because if you just do Hallux,
it's a guy's toes on there.
Tim Ferriss: There we go.
Kevin Rose: That makes sense.
Okay.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
So do you see what I'm talking about?
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Oh, it's beautiful.
That's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: Isn't that gorgeous?
Kevin Rose: Oh, it's so good.
Tim Ferriss: It's so good.
So if people go to twitter.com/househallux,
House Hallux is one of the eight greater houses.
Each of these houses has its background coming
out on the Cockpunch podcast, which by the
way, you were gone for this, but debuted at
number one in fiction across all of Apple
Podcasts.
Ended up at top 50 or top 60 across all of
Apple Podcasts.
People are now listening to these and getting
really into it.
People are enjoying it.
Particularly once I made the, and my team,
I should give them credit, the higher res,
full body images and PFPs available.
I put out a video on YouTube, which showed
people how to convert their PFP into this
Van Gogh self-portrait styled oil painting.
People have been having a blast.
They've been having so much fun and things
have gone pretty bananas.
There's a lot of creativity being unleashed.
This was the hope, and hence the description
of the project as emergent, long fiction.
Emergent, not just emergent from me, but emergent
from the audience.
So for instance, there is this unofficial
Discord.
I said from the outset, I wasn't going to
make a Discord because everybody told me Discord
is where all the evil comes out.
I have, however, ended up chancing upon this
unofficial Discord where, I might have sent
this to you in Brendan via text, they had
AI driven cockfights with different Cock Punch
characters on this discord.
I have never seen anything like this.
It was so funny that I was sweating through
my clothing.
It was beyond hilarious.
Kevin Rose: It was rock climbing.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
It was like rock climbing, but a lot more
hilarious.
And what they did, it was genius, so they
had people opt in to competing.
So let's say they have brackets, like an NCAA
tournament, and each character would feed
in their name and their traits.
So the traits and attributes that you would
find on, say, Cowpunchers.
And then the moderator who was also the commentator,
kind of like a sports commentator, would feed
this into Chat GPT.
And he would add a prompt like: describe an
epic battle between or among, and list all
these characters with their traits.
And then Chat GPT would spit out this fight
scene.
And he then on Discord in a voice channel,
would read this for everybody as it's happening,
as it's being generated, so there's a live
sports element to it.
There was somebody else in the channel who,
because a bunch of these characters, especially
from the Omikawa have an instrument which
is called a shamisen, which is a traditional
Japanese instrument.
Somehow he managed to pull up this super aggressive,
traditional shamisen music.
So you have this commentator who's reading
the live fights, the play-by-play like a boxing
match from the 1950s while this crazy Japanese
music is playing.
And simultaneously the text thread is going
crazy with all these people commenting and
throwing in memes.
It was beyond hilarious and so exciting and
fucking fun.
It was so fun.
And I had nothing to do with it.
Look, I provided a few of the raw materials
perhaps in the form of a funny name, some
artwork, the attributes.
And the naming of the attributes, by the way,
not accidental.
If people look at the attributes, most people
have not paid enough attention to the naming
of the weapons and the attributes.
I spent at least 10 hours just on naming.
So that will become more relevant later.
But the way that this is unfolding has been
super fun.
It's been super fun.
Kevin Rose: It's so cool.
Tim Ferriss: There was a period of time where
I was just like, "Fuck all these NFT traders.
Fuck these people."
I was so annoyed because there was so much
unnecessary spinning of conspiracy theories,
like, "Tim's going to send all the money to
his own charity and buy a Lamborghini and
run off to Bermuda.
This whole thing's a scam.
It's a rug pull."
And I'm like, "What are you talking about?
I put everything in the FAQ.
I told you all of the conditions, all of the
objectives.
Stop it.
Just fucking stop it."
But there is I think, I would imagine, you
tell me, but inevitably this cycle of over-exuberance,
as soon as the floor price drops by 0.001
ETH, 10% of the people lose their minds and
become children.
Kevin Rose: Here's the thing, here's the thing.
This is the best advice I can give you Tim,
is that having been here in my wise old age
of six months longer than you have, seven
months, whatever.
Tim Ferriss: Which is like 10 years in NFT
time.
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
I can tell you that what happens is you, there
are a lot of flippers that come in, obviously
that are looking like, "How can I, 2 or 3X
this in two minutes?"
And then eventually you'll realize, and it's
really cool that we're starting to see this
happen in Moonbirds, where a lot of that chatter
has gone away.
And it's more about the long term holders
that understand that great projects, great
visions, great businesses, they're not built
over six months.
They're built over the next decade.
And so if we're going to do that, they're
signing up and believing in us as builders
over the long term.
And I think that's where you'll get to is
you'll get to people that are like, "Oh, I
love the podcast.
I love the lore.
I love the backstory.
I love what Tim's doing here.
I'm a holder for the long term."
And what you'll see is your percent listed
will drop over time.
And that will be because you're getting in
some more of the long term holders that believe
in the project over the next decade, which
is very exciting.
And I already see that happening with your
collection today, which is great.
The one thing I will say that is amazing is
you had one of your golden cocks, which is
your kind of your signature cock, go 55 ETH
which is just insane.
Tim Ferriss: It's wild.
Kevin Rose: 55.550 ETH is one of what your
cocks went for.
And it has the gold balls attribute.
Tim Ferriss: It's full gold.
Kevin Rose: It's full gold.
Tim Ferriss: That is full gold.
Kevin Rose: Well, copper too, right?
Tim Ferriss: It might be copper.
It might be copper.
There are a couple of different options.
Let's see here.
There's gold, pewter I believe, which is the
silver equivalent, but I thought pewter was
much cooler, and then copper because I love
copper.
That's a long story, but I really have an
affinity for copper.
There are a bunch of metals I have affinities
for.
Copper is one.
Kevin Rose: One question I have for you is
you have an attribute called the Circle of
Eight, but my zen hat on says that's an enso.
So is it an enso or no?
Tim Ferriss: An Enso?
Describe for the audience what an enso is.
Kevin Rose: It's just like the Japanese symbol
for...
You can look up, go and type an E-N-S-O, enso
into Google images and you'll see it's standard
zen circle.
The one with the single stroke.
Tim Ferriss: Can you pull up one of those
characters as you're looking at them?
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I have them up right now.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Look at the shirt.
What's on the shirt?
Can you see what's on it?
Kevin Rose: It's green.
Hold on, let me get back to it.
I had it.
Yeah, it's a green shirt.
And it's got the single...
Oh, there's a dragon.
It's a dragon eating its own tail.
Okay.
My bad.
I thought it was more of the single stroke
like zen symbol.
You know what I'm talking about, right?
Tim Ferriss: It may not be unrelated to that.
Kevin Rose: It's not too far off.
Oh, Interesting.
Tim Ferriss: It may not be unrelated.
That is a dragon eating its own tail in what
is called an ouroboros.
And there are a lot of kind of hyper proud
liberal arts folks who use this word or mythological
reference in snarky magazine articles, but
they don't actually have a full understanding
of the mythological significance and variation
on this concept of the ouroboros.
So people can look into it.
But you are going to ask about them.
I will say that I think the Circle of Eight
are overlooked.
Kevin Rose: Well, there's only seven of them
though.
Why aren't there eight of them?
Tim Ferriss: There is an eighth.
He's in there.
He's in there somewhere.
Kevin Rose: He's not tagged to circles of
eight though.
And it could be a sheep.
Tim Ferriss: He's not tagged.
No, it can't be a sheep because they're all
cocks, but yes.
Kevin Rose: All right.
So there's not a single ball-less one out
of all them, they're all...?
Tim Ferriss: There's not a single what?
Ball-less one?
Kevin Rose: Yeah, they're all cocks.
They're all male.
Tim Ferriss: It's Cockpunch.
Yes.
They're all cocks.
Kevin Rose: You're like, "Kevin, maybe the
title may have tipped you off.
It's actually Cockpunch."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
It's very much...
But that is one of the outstanding mysteries
in the Realm of Varlata which as described
by the seventh scribe in the first episode
of the podcast is there are several very significant
outstanding questions.
And one is: where are the women?
We assume we got here by birth.
Kevin Rose: Is this season two for you?
Tim Ferriss: If we did, there must...
Question mark, question mark, question mark.
Kevin Rose: Ooh, interesting lady punch.
I could go way worse, but I'm not going to
say anything.
Tim Ferriss: You could go cuntslap.com.
Kevin Rose: You're definitely going to bleep
that out.
Tim Ferriss: No, I just love saying that because
I know that some aspirational squatter's going
to go out and buy Cuntslap everything.
He'd be like, "You didn't get cuntslap.eth.
Now you can buy it from me for $20,000."
And I'll be like, "Enjoy that one.
I'm never going to use it."
Kevin Rose: Yeah, that's how they do it.
Tim Ferriss: But I have a lot of ideas.
I'm not committing to a decade of building
X, Y, or Z.
I've made this clear from the outset.
I'm going to do this as long as it's energy
feeding, which I think is part of the reason
why a lot of traders have ditched, which I'm
thrilled about.
And not to say that traders are trivial.
They provide liquidity and a really important
function, and I understand why they do what
they do.
But, as somebody pointed out on Twitter who
is a holder of one of these Cockpunch NFTs,
they said, "With every secondary transaction
you are getting closer to the community that
you want."
I thought about that.
I was like, "Fuck, that's true."
And I've seen that-
Kevin Rose: Damn, did you tweet that out?
Because that some sage shit I need to tweet
out.
Tim Ferriss: It wasn't mine, it was somebody
else.
I apologize that I can't remember the proper
attribution.
But it was like, "With every secondary sale,
you are getting closer to the community that
you want."
And it's so true when you think about it.
Even if I look at the last...
When did this even happen?
God, it seems like six months since I launched,
but it's only been two weeks.
Exactly.
I will say, oh man, when I talk to people
who have been deep in the trenches with NFTs
for six months, a year, two years, it is looking
at a before and after photo of Obama when
he got elected and four years later.
Kevin Rose: He's dead to the world.
Tim Ferriss: People are worn down.
They've got the thousand yard stare.
Their black hairs all gone gray.
I'm like, "Holy shit.
You really got to pace yourself."
Yeah.
Oh my God.
So intense.
Kevin Rose: I'm excited for you, man.
I think this is a fun, creative chapter for
you and I love that you're not saying, "This
is my next great book.
This is my next..."
It's a fun outlet.
Tim Ferriss: It's a fun outlet.
But I want to rewind and echo something that
you said, and we hadn't had that much booze.
This was in Santa Monica, and I don't know
if we were recording, but I was showing you
some of the artwork and I was getting excited.
I was explaining some of the stuff I was thinking
about.
And you said, and maybe you were joking, you
can tell me, but you're like, "This might
be the biggest thing that you've done."
And I don't think that's a 0% likelihood.
Kevin Rose: No, I meant that when I said that.
Tim Ferriss: I know that sounds fucking crazy,
but I don't think it's 0%.
I really don't.
Kevin Rose: No, the reason I say that is because,
and I truly did mean that when I said it is
because of one simple thing.
And it's funny, just in full transparency,
a handful of friends are like, "What's Tim
doing?
What's this Cockpunch thing?"
And they come up to me because they know I
know you.
And they're wanting to know, "Is this crazy?
Has he gone off the deep end?"
Blah, blah.
And my answer is always very succinct and
it's on point, and then I say, "You don't
understand, Tim is a creativity factory and
if you point that in the right direction..."
Look at those triceps by the way.
Tim Ferriss: Look at these triceps.
Oh God, look at that forearm of those triceps.
Kevin Rose: If you point that in the right
direction, you're going to have just something
that could turn into a franchise and something
that is much bigger than you are even imagining.
Oftentimes we see this as in technology all
the time, whether it be Twitter or Instagram
or you name it.
I can probably point to 15 companies that
everyone thought when they launched that it
was a fun little fad, and then it snowballs
into something bigger and bigger and bigger.
And all of a sudden it would not shock me
if five years from now, and I know you're
not saying this is me saying this, but you're
in some major motion picture, crazy shit,
multi-print book like world where this blows
up into something much bigger.
And so when I looked at that, I said, "Wow,
if you take your non-fiction world and move
it to fiction, this is your creativity shifting
to that fiction world," which I want to watch.
I want to watch every chapter of that.
So I'm excited for you.
Tim Ferriss: Thanks, man.
Kevin Rose: Or it could be nothing.
Tim Ferriss: I've had a lot of fun.
Or it could be nothing.
Kevin Rose: But that's the best part is you
haven't promised that this is the future.
You're saying, "I'm going to have a great
time and let's see what happens."
Tim Ferriss: I have the emergency exit.
If I get sick of it, I'm out.
And what you described, maybe.
I don't think that's inevitable.
I do not think that's inevitable.
Because my goal is to create something that
can perpetuate without me.
That's always the objective.
The last time I gave an interview for the
Four Hour Work Week, 10 years ago?
Still one of the top books on Amazon.
Kevin Rose: That's a great point.
Tim Ferriss: And so my intention, and here's
the thing, there's a cohesion and a shared
incentive and an alignment with NFTs that
does not quite exist with books.
And that's very interesting to me.
So I'm studying this very deeply, having a
lot of conversations.
I could ditch in a month if I deal with a
thousand consecutive dick faces on the internet
maybe.
But so far it's been pretty easy relative
to all the things that I've had to contend
with over the last say, decade.
It's been pretty easy to discard that just
because the nonsense is clearly nonsense.
And the people spouting nonsense are generally
spouting that nonsense to other people who
are spouting nonsense.
And even in two weeks just being able to withstand
the heat in the kitchen and staying in the
kitchen-
Kevin Rose: Oh, then you're good.
Tim Ferriss: A lot of that has resolved itself.
Kevin Rose: It's going to calm down.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
Yeah.
Oh, in 10 days it's already calmed down.
And so for me, this is when the interesting
stuff starts.
This is when things start to get interesting.
When I have a critical mass of people as evidenced
by this unofficial Discord and these competitions,
which were unbelievably entertaining.
I think this could get to a point where people
pay just to be a spectator at these competitions.
I know that's a strong statement.
Kevin Rose: Look at esports man.
It's freaking huge.
Tim Ferriss: It blew my mind.
So I think everyone who did that, a lot of
credit.
I was flabbergasted.
It was truly one of the greater holy shit
moments I've had in the last several years.
So if that is what's happening within two
weeks, oh my God, holy shit.
And I'm excited.
I'm having fun.
And also you think about non-fiction and all
of the...
If you're a responsible non-fiction writer
who is engaging in creative non-fiction, but
within the broad category of creative, you
need to adhere to a certain factual basis
that is verifiable when you remove those limiters
and you enter the world of fiction, which
requires, if you're going to do it well, I
think some degree of consistency and you need
to ensure that storylines mesh to some degree.
But when you remove some of the common constraints
of non-fiction, holy moly, what I have experienced
is that you tap a wellspring of creativity
that is enormous, that just does not exist
when you are writing fact-based, I don't want
to call it literature, but when you were trying
to produce fact-based writing.
And I'm having fun, man.
I'm having so much fun.
And it opens the door to so many things.
I was talking to somebody on my team today
and I was saying, "I've never ever wanted
to sell Tim Ferriss branded shit."
The idea of somebody walking around with a
Tim Ferriss Show t-shirt with my fucking face
on it that makes me want to puke.
Kevin Rose: Well, I have your thong, the limited
edition one needed to get.
It was great.
Tim Ferriss: The limited edition thong with
my face right on the balls.
That's true.
You did get the one of one.
That is the first one of one I produced.
Yeah, you're welcome.
Happy anniversary.
But the idea of having my face on say a t-shirt
just always made me puke a little in my mouth.
Kevin Rose: That doesn't feel right.
Tim Ferriss: No, just never wanted to do it.
But people do that stuff.
Kevin Rose: Who does their face on a t-shirt?
I can see your logo.
Tim Ferriss: Well, even just Tim Ferriss on
a shirt, it feels weird to me.
So it's just too narc...
I'm sure I'm a narcissist, but I'm not that
narcissistic.
I just couldn't get there.
But the idea of having a small subculture
of people who at some point might walk around
with a Cockpunch logo on their shirt, probably
without Cockpunch on it, that would be too
in your face, but a logo on it where anyone
who sees it knows.
And that can be the Fight Club wink.
That's fun.
That's super fun.
And I'm not saying I'm going to do that, but
it's fun for me to imagine that being a possibility.
So suddenly all of these handcuffs that I'd
placed on myself for good reasons around what
I could or couldn't do are gone.
They're completely gone.
It's called Cockpunch for fuck's sake.
I can do whatever I want.
It's fun.
Kevin Rose: I love that.
Tim Ferriss: I'm really excited about it.
Kevin Rose: I have one awkward question for
you.
And it just popped in my mind as a consumer
of your podcast, but something you may not
agree to divulge and which we can cut it out.
But there was a point here a few minutes ago
where you said The Four Hour Work Week is
still on the New York Times bestselling list,
right?
Tim Ferriss: No, I didn't say that.
I said it's still one of the top selling books
on Amazon.
Kevin Rose: Top selling books in Amazon.
So yeah, you're right, because those are different
things.
I'm sure there's a lot of people...
And Tim take this as I'm being like...
If you're willing to divulge, a lot of people
would be curious, what did you receive for
the signing bonus to do that book?
Because it was your first big book.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, for Four Hour Work Week?
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
And then what does it look like over time?
And then what do you make now on that book
per year?
Can you talk about that?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah I can talk about that.
Kevin Rose: Forget the ego stuff and I think
it's really interesting.
Tim Ferriss: I'll talk about it.
I'm happy to talk about it.
And these are not going to be...
Well, in the case of the ongoing annual stuff,
I'm not going to have an exact number, but
I can give you an idea.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, yeah.
Just rough estimates.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, rough estimates.
So a few things on the book publishing side.
And I may have to take a pee break because
after the ketones and key limes and tequila
and soda water...
Kevin Rose: We can also stop in a minute.
We're at two hours or something.
Tim Ferriss: No, I'm having fun.
I'm happy to go this.
We're two hours, 24 minutes in.
But this is a good episode, we're covering
a lot.
My advance for the four hour work week, which
was paid out in four to six installments,
I want to say, I don't recall exactly, over
probably a year and a half was $75,000, if
I remember correctly.
Kevin Rose: Your first book.
You approached them or they approached you
or how did this...?
Tim Ferriss: Well, the way it happened is
a long story.
I ended up finding a very good editor named
Steven Hanselman who had just become an agent.
He was untested largely, as an agent, but
I trusted his taste and we hit it off.
He then took the book and pitched it to a
bunch of editors, 27 or 29 of which rejected
it in some cases rudely, really rudely.
Ultimately sold it on one of our last meetings
in person in New York City with editors and
publishers.
And Crown took a risk at the time, Crown within
Random House.
Now I think it's Harmony Books.
The publishing world has a lot of shuffling
constantly, so it's hard to keep track.
But I believe, and the person who gave the
go ahead was Steve Ross at the time, I think
it was Steve Ross.
I think I'm getting his first name right at
then at Crown.
So thank you Steve.
And it was 75k paid out over probably a year
or a year and a half.
Kevin Rose: Now that's in advance, right?
So they're saying if you sell that many books...
You have to break that first, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, exactly.
So we're prepaying you for a certain number
of books and if you exceed it, then you get
the royalty.
And the royalty per copy for hard cover is
going to be anywhere between 10% and 15%-
Kevin Rose: What does that mean net net?
Tim Ferriss: ... of cover price?
Well...
Kevin Rose: Couple bucks.
Tim Ferriss: A couple bucks.
So let's just say it's 20 bucks and let's
make it...
It's not going to be 10%.
So it'll be, let's just call it 15%, that'll
be $3 a book.
From that $3 though keep in mind you got to
pay taxes and you also have to beforehand
pay your agent, which is generally going to
be 15%.
And then anything else that comes out of it.
Kevin Rose: You sold millions of copies.
Tim Ferriss: I sold millions of copies.
It took time.
It did not flash boil as quickly as say Atomic
Habits or as quickly as the Subtle Art of
Not Giving a Fuck.
It did not flash boil as quickly as either
of those books.
It took some time.
It came out in April of 2007, it did not hit
number one New York Times, which it did first
on the monthly business list until, I want
to say August.
It took some time.
The initial print run was 10,000 copies and
it sold out and then nobody could buy the
book anywhere.
Kevin Rose: Wow.
Crazy.
Tim Ferriss: Which is a quality problem and
it's actually a significant problem.
And that is the advanced story, or at least
the numbers on the advance.
Kevin Rose: So what's your yearly look like
at this point?
Is it like 50 grand or...?
Tim Ferriss: Well let me...
I asked this recently.
Let me try to pull up my text thread.
I was trying to come up with this number recently.
Kevin Rose: Just a rough estimate's fine too.
It doesn't have to be...
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I just don't want to...
You know how particular I am.
I don't want to misrepresent anything.
Let's see.
Kevin Rose: It's sub 100K, is that right?
Or more?
You're probably selling over a hundred thousand
copies a year.
Tim Ferriss: Maybe a 100 to 150K.
Kevin Rose: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: I've written and published now
five books that were number one New York Times
and/or Wall Street Journal, and many of them
stuck for a very long time.
I'm looking at a text thread with my agent
and he sent a photo, which is pretty fun with
Four Hour Work Week on the trending rack at
Barnes and Noble after amazing 15 years.
After 15 years.
Kevin Rose: Holy shit.
Tim Ferriss: Now on this rack you have Think
and Grow Rich, which has been around for decades,
you have The Intelligent Investor, Benjamin
Grant, been around for decades, Four Hour
Work Week, the Millionaire Next Door, Poor
Rich Dad.
Kevin Rose: Poor Rich Dad.
Yeah, exactly.
I was going to say that one's always in there.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Power Positive Thinking.
I'm just going to name a few because why not.
Trust and Inspire, I'm not familiar, Tribe
of Mentors, so I've got two on this rack.
Atomic Habits, Jordan Peterson, 12 Rules for
Life, The 10X Rule and a number of others.
So on the trending rack, I'm actually in good
longevity company with a number of these.
For 15 years afterwards, it's still trending.
Kevin Rose: You're like a musical artist,
artist at this point.
It's basically, if you're insert any Queen
or Michael Jackson, whatever, there's just
ongoing royalties that just trickle in over
time.
Because you get to that point.
It's evergreen content.
Tim Ferriss: It's evergreen by design.
And I'm looking at this here.
Kevin Rose: That's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: I would say all of my books on
an annual basis, these are not the most successful
books of all time, this is not Harry Potter,
but this is probably top 1% in terms of earnings
and track record for non-fiction books.
And my total royalties pretax would be in
the hundreds of thousands of dollars per year.
And I don't know the exact, on that...
Kevin Rose: Campbell Soup in [inaudible 02:30:37].
Tim Ferriss: Say it again?
Kevin Rose: I was just going to say-
Tim Ferriss: It buys it buy a lot of Campbell
Soup.
But let's just take it as an example, I have
put many hundreds of thousands of dollars
into the development of Cockpunch and I won't
bore people of all the specifics, but there's
a lot of money that's gone into Cockpunch.
Kevin Rose: That's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
So no, this is just to say-
Kevin Rose: You're like, "I've taken all the
money from Four Hour Work Week and poured
it right back into Cockpunchs so you motherfuckers..."
Tim Ferriss: No, well it's not so much a guilt
trip.
It's just to say, I think it's crazy to think
about the fact that I could take almost all
or all of my royalties for all of my books,
decades of work, all of the proceeds that
I get from that I put into an NFT project,
which doesn't highlight that an NFT project
done well costs a lot of money, although I
do think it requires some.
It's to highlight the fact that part of my
reason for engaging with Web3 and NFTs was
the promise that artists could resurrect,
in a sense, their creative powers through
an ongoing royalty, which turns out, this
is a shocker and was a shocker to a lot of
people, is not automatically baked in and
guaranteed by your smart contract across all
platforms.
It's platform dependent.
Kevin Rose: Let's be real, and let me give
you some real talk now, Tim.
Tim Ferriss: Real talk.
Kevin Rose: Okay.
Real talk is that you've had 5,396 ETH in
total volume.
Your creator fee is 6.9%.
And I'm not, please let everyone know on this
podcast what you did it no one does, which
is the primary sale, you gave all the money
to charity.
The secondary sale, you're saying, "This is
what's going to maintain the project," which
I think is awesome.
That's what you want to do.
Tim Ferriss: To be clear, I actually said,
"Tim might use it on whiskey and whores."
I didn't even address the secondary sales.
Kevin Rose: Giving the signal again, the second
piece of that may kick in.
Tim Ferriss: Oh boy.
Kevin Rose: We can cut that out.
Jesus, I'm sorry Tim.
I didn't mean to say that.
Tim Ferriss: That's all right.
That's okay.
Kevin Rose: So 5,396 total ETH times 0.069,
your creator fee is 372 ETH.
So 372 obviously times, let's just say ETH
is at 1200, that means if you've already broken
even, you're at $446,000 in secondary sales.
Tim Ferriss: Have not even recouped my costs
for Cockpunch yet, but yes.
Kevin Rose: Costs for more than a half million?
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Kevin Rose: Wow.
That's crazy.
Well, and you have to pay taxes on this because
this is revenue.
Tim Ferriss: And yeah, that is not counting
my time.
I'm working at below minimum wage given the
number of hours I've put into this.
But if we discount that, if we're just considering
hours for contractors, the costs, which I
view as an investment for artists, for my
team members who are allocating a significant
portion of let's just say their annual salary
to these things, I do not think I have yet
broken even.
And I'm totally-
Kevin Rose: I think you're going to be okay.
Tim Ferriss: ... fine with it.
I'm totally fine with it.
I am totally fine with it.
Kevin Rose: You're going to break even, dude.
There's no doubt.
Tim Ferriss: I'm not worried.
Yeah, I'm not worried.
I'm not worried.
Kevin Rose: As the storyline matures, the
lore matures, your commitment matures, there's
no doubt that...
Dude.
Well, I won't even say what other projects
I can compare these against, but you are...
Tim Ferriss: The project's doing well.
The project's doing well.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: The project's doing well.
And what's most exciting to me is the trend
that I am seeing and the coalescing of a community
of people who are actually excited about it
and thoughtfully excited about it.
They're not just drunk on Cockpunch fumes,
they're actually thinking about the lore,
they're tracking the lore.
They're tracking some of the details that
a lot of folks have missed.
And they're paying attention, and they're
excited about it.
They're having fun with it, which is the whole
fucking point.
Kevin Rose: This is exactly what I'm most
excited about the Moon Birds community and
what we're doing over there is that we're
finally getting the point where I feel like
the community is tipped over and said, "We're
in this for the long term."
They're excited about what we're building.
They excited about some of the novel mechanics
that we're doing on the technical side that
haven't been done before, or being done in
different ways.
And once you get there, you're in a great
place with the project, because you feel good,
you feel energized to go into work and really
put in more energy into this, which is what
we can all hope for.
I will say a couple little things to hit before
we wrap things up.
One thing certainly worth checking out for
everyone out there, especially high risk folks,
and Tim, I purposely put this in the rundown
so that we could chat about it, but there
is a mode new to iOS called Apple lockdown
mode.
And if you go into settings on your iPhone,
you'll probably do this because I know you're
paranoid and like this shit, but if you enable
lockdown mode, it actually disables five very
common things that you would typically allow
on the iPhone.
But it prevents most of the compromises that
happen from state actors, like-
Tim Ferriss: That's a good idea.
Kevin Rose: ... the governments and sophisticated
attackers.
Yeah.
It locks it all down.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
I'm looking at this-
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: You have protect devices against
extremely rare [inaudible 02:39:50] cyber
attacks.
Kevin Rose: So, it's things like if you get
a lot of payloads, meaning the vulnerabilities
will come over SMS, or text message.
And if you get something from, say someone
that you don't know, it by default blocks
them.
Things, like just obvious things you should
have enabled, it does cripple a few things
in terms of the functionality of the iPhone.
Kevin Rose: Anything else before we wrap things
up?
Tim Ferriss: Well, I'm kind of curious.
You have a couple of bullets.
I love your spelling.
Am I done with ayahuasca?
I'm assuming that is the question.
Kevin Rose: That's right.
Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And then about investing.
Let's talk about those two.
So real quick on the ayahuasca front, let
me just preface this a bit in that I would
consider you to be the first person I ever
heard about ayahuasca, let's call it eight
years ago or whatever the fuck it was, a long
time ago, it was from you, and nobody was
doing that.
It was like you had to get a proper shaman,
blah, blah.
Now, Los Angeles, CVS is doing ayahuasca things
at night.
It's like everywhere.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Oh, God.
Kevin Rose: What?
What's...
Hey, you.
You fucked everyone, in that you created this
crazy trend.
And have you found durable, lasting effects
from it?
Like, would you still recommend it for most
people, or what's your take on that?
Tim Ferriss: I wouldn't recommend it for most
people.
I have found durable benefits, and I've also
found unpredictable risks.
So, I will say that about a year and a half
ago, maybe two years ago, I had an extended
deep depressive episode for several months
precipitated by two nights of consuming ayahuasca.
And there are reasons for that.
It's not unexplainable.
It was related to a lot of the content of
that experience in a certain sense of meaninglessness
and nihilism that was, I think, a predictable
result of the content and experience that
I went through.
And I think in some way the conclusion, landing
in this void of meaninglessness and nihilism
is justified, but that doesn't make it productive.
And it was certainly not psychologically beneficial.
So, after that experience, I decided to take
a hiatus from partaking.
And there are significant, not just psychological,
but in some cases physiological risks associated
with ayahuasca.
You can experience, especially if you're on
concurrent medications like certain SSRIs,
serotonin syndrome, you can have severe, severe
side effects.
So this is not a trivial undertaking.
And I have largely in the last year, year
and a half, paced down significantly any consumption
of psychedelics.
I think that they will be an ongoing component
of my life until it's game over, or at least
this game over, and I transition from this
physical forum, should we say.
I do think that [inaudible 02:45:39]-
Kevin Rose: ... that you truly are.
Tim Ferriss: That's right, until we all ascend
to the Valhalla of Cockpunch.
But I do anticipate it'll be an ongoing aspect
and important ritual component in my life,
but I have dialed back the frequency substantially.
Kevin Rose: Let me ask you a question.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: Did you see the benefits degrade
over time, in meaning that if you had to go
back and talk to your first ayahuasca self,
let's call it eight years ago or whatever
it was, would you say, "Hey, Tim-"
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, 10 plus years ago now.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, let's say 10 plus years
ago, would you say, "Hey, Tim, do it 10 times,
or do it five times, or do it whatever," is
there a beneficial return the more that you
do it, or is that-
Tim Ferriss: Tough question to answer.
I think it depends a lot on the individual.
It also depends on the reasons for which you
are using it.
I would say I wouldn't have said that to myself.
I wouldn't have said, "Do it 10 times and
call it quits."
I wouldn't have said that.
Here's what I probably would've said; I would've
said, number one, "If you take this seriously,
the deeper you go, the more interesting it
becomes.
If you pursue very qualified training through
people who have a proven lineage of focusing
on this for hundreds of years, you can go
very, very deep, and it will get more interesting."
I would have simultaneously said, "Be very
cautious about how deep you go because you
can get lost.
If this is not your tradition, if this is
not your culture, if you have not been steeped
in this, if you didn't start drinking ayahuasca
when you were five years old," which is when
a lot of these, let's just call them professionals,
will start drinking, is when they're five,
six, or seven years old.
Kevin Rose: Wow.
Like a full dose or just little tasters?
Tim Ferriss: I don't know how it's introduced.
Probably at smaller doses, but very quickly
getting into full doses.
Very, very quickly, getting into full doses.
Kevin Rose: Is it fun when you do a little
cough syrup, a little on the side, or do you
have to do a full dose to get the benefits?
I've never done it.
You know that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah, I do.
I will say, here's-
Kevin Rose: Can I say one thing, Tim?
Can I say one thing?
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Kevin Rose: Just let me say one thing.
Tim Ferriss: You can say two things.
You can say three things.
Kevin Rose: If you decide to do it again this
year, if you would have me, I would do it
with you, finally, after like 10 years.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
All right.
That's interesting.
I will not hold you to that, but that's good
to know.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I would love to man.
I know that you would be a good guy to...
I know you'd be a good friend, and I know
you'd be a good shoulder, and I know there's...
Having to high dose mushrooms, I cried and
wept over my dad's passing, over a lot of
shit that obviously comes up, and you need
a support structure, and I know you would
be a fantastic friend at that, so I would
love that if you would have me at some point.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
Thanks, Kevin.
And also, the meditation training you've been
doing will be instrumental.
It will be incredibly, incredibly helpful.
So, that's good to know.
And I will say that...
I'll just wrap up quickly, the advice I would
have given to my younger self.
So number one is the deeper you go, the more
interesting it will become, assuming that
you have proper guidance from people who have
a proven track record before this was fashionable
of over generations cultivating an awareness
and toolkit for interacting with these spaces.
Yeah.
Kevin Rose: I was just going to say one little
tidbit to that.
Even just being out here a couple months,
I hear, "Hey, come to our ayahuasca little
thing in the LA Hills, blah, blah, blah."
And it seems very commercial at this point.
In my head, I was always like, "I'm only going
to trust Tim on this shit, because he's got
that OG, that original shit," like the good
stuff, the good.
But you [inaudible 02:50:08] you must feel
this-
Tim Ferriss: I'm very strict.
You know I'm strict.
You know I'm strict, and I'm very-
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
I know you've only got the best.
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
And I'm very, very, very, very particular
and meticulous about how I assess expertise.
I think that is one of my core forms of expertise,
is assessing expertise.
I think I am very good at it.
Kevin Rose: I agree.
Tim Ferriss: And I think the vast majority
of people who consume these things are children
playing with loaded handguns.
They don't realize the risks they're taking,
and the horrifying episodes generally don't
get a lot of airtime.
So there's a survivorship bias, where people
end up hearing the positive, life altering
experiences.
And then the incorrect conclusion is made,
that the vast majority of experiences are
like that.
And I have not seen any evidence to suggest
that's true.
There are many positive, life altering experiences,
but ayahuasca specifically is a big gun.
It is very powerful.
And the other warning I would give, in addition
to if you go deep, given that you are not
native to this environment, there is a risk
that you will become lost.
And being lost could be an indescribably terrifying
experience, where the line between reality
and what you might perceive as a hyper reality
in this other dimension, or fabricated reality
as a UI, as we perceive it, versus any type
of objective truth, things can get very, very
unclear very quickly.
And I don't expect anyone to understand this
or even take it as reasonable that you could
have that experience if you haven't been there.
But take my word for it, you can get to some
very, very slippery terrain.
Furthermore, I would say no matter how many
times you have done this, doesn't matter if
it's 10, or a hundred, or 200, you always
stand the chance of pulling a joker card from
the deck and getting your fucking ass handed
to you in a very serious way, that has lasting-
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
I don't want to do it anymore.
Tim Ferriss: That has lasting consequences.
Now, I will say, just for you, Kevin, the
group matters.
The group matters.
And I will say more so than perhaps, at least
from a traditional format perspective, the
people in the group matter.
So you are going to have...
This is another reason, or another example
of where I think many people don't-
Kevin Rose: Are you sane though, when you're
doing this?
Like, if I look over at you-
Tim Ferriss: Well, hold on.
Yeah?
Kevin Rose: ... while we're doing this, you're
not going to be doing something crazy?
I'm like, "I'm freaking out.
Fuck, I'm freaking out.
He's masturbating in the corner."
Tim Ferriss: Generally not.
No.
Generally, I'm not like-
Kevin Rose: I'm going to look to you to be
solid ground.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I'm not like the exorcist,
right?
My head is not spinning around while I'm vomiting
in all directions and speaking in tongues.
Things can get very strange, and they almost
certainly will get very strange.
I have never had the experience...
Actually, I take that back.
Well, in my first few experiences, there were
one or two times where I felt out of control,
fully out of control, and was completely dislocated
from anything resembling this reality.
But generally speaking, now, or in recent
history, I can go through very, very, very,
very challenging experiences.
But if someone near me says, "Tim, are you
okay," or, "Tim, how are you doing," I can
reply to that in perfectly coherent English,
even if I am, by all subjective interpretations,
completely removed from time, space, identity.
Kevin Rose: That's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: I can still respond to that,
which is a developed...
I think that's a cultivated skill, at least
for me.
But the fact of the matter remains that I
could not have foreseen how violently I would
be destabilized from that experience a year
and a half, two years ago.
And I think that was in part due to a degree
of overconfidence, after many rounds for a
non-clinician, for non-professional.
The professionals drink four or five nights
a week and do so for years and years and years
on end.
So anyone who's like, "I've done ayahuasca
10 times, I understand ayahuasca," you are
setting yourself up for spiritual head kick.
Kevin Rose: The reason I'm excited about this,
and tell me if this is foolish, and I'm fine
with you saying that; The one thing that I
really appreciate about this practice of meditation
is that there's two things.
One, it's Henry slaps his legs and he says,
"Just, this, just this.
This is the moment, just this," and that really
snaps me back into this is the moment.
And the second piece is that this idea of
surrender, where you have something that's
facing you and you're like, "That's just a
thought, let's surrender back to the moment,"
is a big piece of this practice.
And do you think that either of those things
would be helpful in this, or is that just-
Tim Ferriss: 100%.
I'll tell you how they'll be helpful in my
experience and how they'll be a hindrance,
or how they can be a hindrance.
So, on the helpful side, in these very, let's
call them unusual and alternate experiences
of reality in say an ayahuasca experience,
and you can have nothing nights also, by the
way.
You get a brew that's super weak, or you just
simply for whatever reason, have your body
veto the experience.
You can have null experiences.
It's pretty wild.
I have had those.
They're rare, but I've had experiences where
I've had three cups, which I never do, three
drinks, and have been more sober than I am
right now, because I had one real drink, or
two real drinks.
And I don't have a good explanation for how
that happens.
But let's just assume we're talking about
the full ride and you're in.
There is an expression, and this is used in
therapy, but it's especially applicable, I
think to some of these stronger psychedelic
experiences, which is what you resist persists.
So, if you're having an emotion, it's not
that the emotion is the problem.
It's your response to the emotion that's the
problem.
Kevin Rose: Right, of course.
Tim Ferriss: So that is very much, I think
compatible, spanning the gap between what
we might consider meditation and a psychedelic
experience.
It's the same.
Kevin Rose: Very cool.
Tim Ferriss: It's just magnified.
If you resist something in meditation, there
is a certain consequence.
If you resist something in psychedelics, it's
that consequence times a hundred.
So, if you're able to rehearse, and practice,
and cultivate the ability to observe without
resisting, it is very helpful.
The risk, and I have seen this, with experienced
meditators, is that they effectively, in the
psychedelic experience, are able to almost
dissociate from a first person experience
and sit on the sidelines.
They don't allow themselves to be taken.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I love that.
That's what I want to do.
Tim Ferriss: And there's a certain wisdom
in that.
There's a safety in that.
But you do not, in my opinion, you don't get
the full experience.
Kevin Rose: You're the coach.
You're watching the players on the field,
and you're like, "Yeah, good job.
Keep it up."
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, exactly.
Clap, clap, clap.
But you're not having the in the zone experience-
Kevin Rose: I get it.
I get it.
Tim Ferriss: ... of being on the playing field
in a way that allows you to ride the light.
Kevin Rose: Well, that's not true surrender
then, because if you're really truly surrendering,
you would let it take you.
Right?
Tim Ferriss: If you allow it...
For meditators, it's a conscious decision,
in many cases.
Unless they just get-
Kevin Rose: Interesting.
They have [inaudible 02:59:14] most people
don't.
Tim Ferriss: Most people don't.
They don't-
Kevin Rose: [inaudible 02:59:20] makes you
feel safe, or?
Tim Ferriss: For most people, it's not surrendering.
It's being taken without thought of there
being an alternative.
Kevin Rose: Right.
Right, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Fuck.
For meditators, I will say, there is a dose
that will render-
Kevin Rose: Oh, sure.
Tim Ferriss: ... you-
Kevin Rose: Like five cups [inaudible 02:59:39]-
Tim Ferriss: ... just a piece of fucking...
It could just be one cup, depending on the
brew.
It could just make you a piece of driftwood
in a hundred foot wave.
There are circumstances in which I don't really
care how good you are-
Kevin Rose: You scare me, stop talking about
it.
Let's just do it [inaudible 02:59:56].
Tim Ferriss: But the room composition matters.
And this is where I'm going to get out there,
so welcome to Crazy Town, everybody.
But when you have proper guidance in the form
of someone who is quarterbacking the experience,
and you have a room of, let's just say four
to eight people, I think around six is really
the sweet spot for me, that is the right size
team for something like this, you are going
to effectively have unprotected spiritual
sex with everybody in that room, which is
part of the reason why I typically do not
drink with any strangers.
I want to know what is under the hood for
people on some level, because it all gets
put on the same shared table in that experience.
And I don't have any scientific proof for
this.
I only have my own direct experience, and
I try to trust in the fidelity of my direct
experience.
Stuff gets shared in that room.
So it's good to have some basic familiarity
of what you're contending with.
Kevin Rose: Scared.
Tim Ferriss: Well, what's interesting, it
doesn't necessarily manifest in a negative
way.
So for instance, I have a friend who I have
sat with many dozens of times now, and we
will often have the exact same experience.
We will see the same things, we will hear
the same things.
We will experience nausea at exactly the same
times, or more interestingly, one of us will
get super nauseous and then the nausea will
disappear and then the other person will vomit,
as if that has been handed off to the other
person, they assume that burden or responsibility
or feeling and they process it for the other
person.
It's very odd.
It's very odd, and it is very, very common.
Kevin Rose: We should get a good crew together.
Tim Ferriss: Who are we going to get?
It's you, me, David Blaine.
Who else are we going to get to fucking...
Mike Shinoda.
Kevin Rose: Put lead singer of Kiss.
I've got to run.
I've got to get back to my girls.
This has been awesome, Tim.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Good to hang, man.
Kevin Rose: It is-
Tim Ferriss: And great to see you, man.
Kevin Rose: I want to say a couple things
real quick before we wrap up.
One, Happy New Year.
I love you.
I miss you.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I love you too, brother.
Kevin Rose: It's always great to do these.
It's been so many fun years of us doing these
ridiculous-
Tim Ferriss: It makes me so happy.
Kevin Rose: ... podcasts.
Speaking of cock punch, this is the cock punch
of podcasts.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it really is.
Kevin Rose: It's just us being ridiculous.
It's good.
Tim Ferriss: #FrontForwardSlouch.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
The thing I love about, just to say this,
because this goes on your main feed, is you
have a very successful podcast that makes
a lot of money doing what you do so well.
And the fact that you would say, hey, I'm
going to dumb it down from time to time and
just have a good time and do these types of
shows, it means a lot, man.
It's like-
Tim Ferriss: Aw, thanks.
Kevin Rose: I think it's core of who we are
though.
We both like to be professionals on some level
and then also just, fuck it, we're going to
die soon.
Let's have a good time.
Right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: I love that.
Tim Ferriss: 100%, man.
I love these conversations.
I miss you.
I miss the family, and I hope to spend more
time in person, so I'll-
Kevin Rose: I'm hoping you come down more
often.
Tim Ferriss: ... at the very least-
Kevin Rose: You're thinking about that, right?
Tim Ferriss: I would like to spend some more
time out there.
It's perfect weather.
There's a lot to be said for it.
Easy access to nature.
I get to hang-
Kevin Rose: I'm just saying, in terms of the
dating life, [inaudible 03:03:52].
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah, that's true.
It's a large playing field out there, and-
Kevin Rose: A lot of pickleball out here.
Tim Ferriss: A lot of pickleball.
A lot of pickleball.
Kevin Rose: I don't even know what that means.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, you don't know what it means.
Oh, what a class act.
I also have a lot of friends out there.
I also have a lot of friends, and it'd be
fun to do these in person, man.
We used to do in person all the time.
We used to do them all the time in person.
Kevin Rose: Always [inaudible 03:04:18].
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: It was so fun.
Kevin Rose: We looked a lot younger.
Less gray ball sacks back in-
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, the ball sacks were really
resplendent in their youthful vigor.
Kevin Rose: I had a ponytail on mine, I had
the whole thing.
It was beautiful.
Tim Ferriss: Little ponytails.
Yeah.
It was a good look.
On that note-
Kevin Rose: Sorry if we offend anyone today.
Obviously we've had a few drinks.
Tim Ferriss: I'm not sorry.
I'm so not sorry.
If you're offended, please, Jesus, relax.
You're going to...
Yeah, unsubscribe.
You're going to die soon.
Have some fun.
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: All right, man.
Kevin Rose: All right, brother.
Tim Ferriss: Good to see you, man.
Kevin Rose: Good to see you.
Tim Ferriss: To everybody listening, I don't
even know if we're going to have show notes,
but maybe.
Tim.blog/podcast.
That's where you can find the more serious
stuff.
And happy holidays and happy new years everybody.
Kevin Rose: Happy new year, everyone.
Tim Ferriss: Happy new year to you too, man.
Kevin Rose: All right, brother, take care.
Tim Ferriss: Take care, buddy.